is to examine consider and report on the
UK's preparations for
and the response to the covid-19
pandemic
this is our first public hearing
there is one word that sums up the
pandemic
for so many and that is the word loss
although there were positive aspects of
the pandemic for example the way in
which communities banded together to
help each other and the vulnerable
millions of people suffered loss
including the loss of friends and family
members the loss of good health both
mental and physical economic loss
the loss of educational opportunities
and the lost social interaction
those who were bereaved lost the most
they lost loved ones and the ability to
mourn properly
it is therefore right that we begin this
first hearing with a minute silence for
those who died
so with those of you who are able to do
so please stand for a minute's silence
thank you
the inquiry will analyze our state of
Readiness for the pandemic and the
response to it as I've said and to
determine whether that level of loss
about which we've just been reflecting
was inevitable
or whether things could have been done
better
my principal aim is to produce reports
and recommendations before another
disaster strikes the four nations of the
United Kingdom
and if it is possible to reduce the
number of deaths the suffering and the
hardship
to that end I've set an ambitious
timetable
and the inquiry team are working
extraordinarily hard to meet it
I will need the full cooperation of the
core participants Witnesses holders of
documents and information and experts
I have a duty to the public to conduct a
thorough fair and independent inquiry
for the whole of the United Kingdom and
I intend to do so
I am acutely conscious that different
parts of the United Kingdom different
communities and different groups of
people suffered in different ways
and the inquiry team and I will ensure
that we listen to them and learn from
them
throughout the inquiry we shall have the
impact on them at the Forefront of our
minds
I am also determined that this inquiry
will not drag on for decades producing
reports when it is too late for them to
do any good
but my terms of reference cover a huge
breadth of issues
and I shall not be able to produce
reports and recommendations in a timely
manner if I grant every application for
core participant status if we cover
every issue that people want covered if
we call for every document examine every
Witness
or cover every issue in as much detail
as some may wish
there is a balance to be struck between
making timely recommendations and the
extent to which we explore every issue a
balance recognized by many of the
bereaved to whom I spoke during the
public consultation on the inquiry's
terms of reference
I assure them and the rest of the public
that I will do everything in my power to
ensure we achieve a sensible and fair
balance and that the inquiry is as
thorough as possible
I will consider submissions on the
various issues and how that balance
should be drawn before I reach any
conclusion
no decision will be taken lightly
one of my earliest decisions was to
break the issues into several modules
and to assign members of the legal team
and the Secretariat to each module
each module involves a gathering of
evidence a process that has already
begun
followed by the public hearings
we cannot hold hearings into each module
at the same time and they will therefore
be heard in sequence
but I wish to emphasize that the order
of the modules does not indicate that I
consider the issues in later modules to
be of any lesser importance
and the teams assigned to them will be
working on them whilst the other modules
are heard
furthermore the order and Broad scope of
the later modules are not yet set in
stone
for the avoidance of doubt and to allay
concerns expressed in the media over the
weekend
I should point out that the standard of
care given to those suffering from covid
including the triage system and the use
of DNR notices is very much an issue
that I intend to explore
and about which I shall receive evidence
in a later module
I've also had to decide on the
designation of core participants for
this the first module
for those who have not been designated a
core participant for module one I hope
they understand that my decision does
not mean I have concluded their concerns
are not legitimate or that they will not
be addressed
if they are reasonable my independent
legal team will investigate them
robustly and pursue them either in
module one or in what we consider to be
a more appropriate module or modules
and they may wish to apply for CP stasis
in that later module or modules
if they do not apply again or have not
yet applied for CP status they can still
contribute to the inquiry there will be
many ways in which individuals and
organizations can do this
for example by providing informational
evidence to the inquiry or suggesting
lines of inquiry to the legal teams
alongside the preparation and hearings
of the modules I intend to conduct a
listening exercise
again there has been some reporting over
the weekend about the design of and
intent behind the proposed listening
exercise
so let me explain a little more
Our intention in conducting the
listening exercise is to ensure that
everyone across the UK who wishes to
contribute to the inquiry can do so in a
less formal setting
people will not have to wait for the
module in which they have an interest to
be heard and they will not have to give
evidence at the public hearings
but their contributions will inform the
inquiry it will provide valuable
evidence to the inquiry about the impact
of the pandemic
and I wish to emphasize that the fact
that someone contributes to the
listening exercise will not prevent them
from giving evidence at the public
hearings of the inquiry if they have
relevant evidence to give
I have taken no decisions as yet
on the witnesses to be called
so no one has been barred from giving
evidence
we shall also find an appropriate way or
ways to commemorate Those whom we have
lost
forgive me in planning and designing the
listening exercise and commemoration
we shall ensure that those most affected
in particular the bereaved are properly
consulted
I promised the bereaved during the
consultation process on the terms of
reference that those who have suffered
will be at the heart of the inquiry
and I intend to keep that promise
as I'm sure they will understand that
does not mean that I can or should
consult them and the other core
participants at every single stage of
our preparation if I did that the
inquiry would go on forever
but today I do invite further
submissions on the listening exercise
and other issues and thereafter we shall
of course be listening to the most
affected as we design the listening
exercise and the camera commemoration or
commemorations
this is a preliminary hearing for module
one preparedness and resilience
several of the core participants have
provided extremely helpful and
constructive submissions and within a
tight time frame I am very grateful to
them
some of the issues raised may be more
relevant to later modules I simply ask
everyone to keep their oral submissions
today as succinct as possible and to
focus on the issues that I have to
consider today
Mr Hugo Keith King's Council Council to
the inquiry will now set those issues
out
Mr Keith
my lady by way of brief introduction
what I'm going to do is commence by
setting out the arrangements for today's
hearing and then introduce the core
participants
I will then turn to say a little about
the background too and the commencement
of this inquiry before introducing this
module module one and addressing some of
the legal issues that arise and which my
lady you have prefaced
the Practical Arrangements
starting necessarily with the
arrangements for today these proceedings
are of course being recorded and live
streamed to other locations
may I say this has certain benefits it
allows the hearing to be followed by a
greater number of people than would be
able to be accommodated within this
hearing room or any over spill room
also in accordance with Section 18 of
the inquiries act 2005 my lady you're
obliged to take such steps as you
consider reasonable to ensure that
members of the public are able to attend
or see and hear a simultaneous
transmission of the proceedings live
streaming goes a long way to satisfying
that obligation
also I need to say that as is routine in
public inquiries where they're made from
time to time be matches mentioned of a
potentially sensitive nature the
broadcasting of the hearing will be
conducted with a three-minute delay and
this provides the opportunity for the
fee to be paused if anything unexpected
is aired which should not be but my lady
we don't expect any such matters to
arise in the course of today
representation
let me turn to that
present today whether in person or
remotely and excluding myself and the
inquiry legal counsel and solicitor team
who are here our Council and solicitor
teams representing 28 core participants
in module one
all the core participants are therefore
legally represented I don't propose to
read out the names of the legal
Representatives my lady knows well that
they are set out at Tab 4 of your bundle
of those legal Representatives I believe
that 22 are present before you today and
six are attending remotely
and then most importantly the core
participants
the core participants know who they are
but I should explain for others that
they are entities organizations or
persons with a significant legal
interest in module one and to therefore
have enhanced rights to participate in
this process
each of them
those appearing before you today
remotely or in person were granted this
status by you for the purposes of this
module under rule five of the inquiry
rules
the list of the core participants is
also in your bundle but but I intend to
read them out so that when we all know
who they are there is no significance in
the order of the names that I will read
covid-19 bereaved families for justice
Scottish covid-19 families for justice
covid-19 bereaved families for justice
Camry Northern Ireland covid-19 bereaved
families for justice the chancellor of
the duchy of Lancaster the cabinet
office his Majesty's Treasury
the Secretary of State for Health and
Social care the Secretary of State for
the home Department the Secretary of
State for business energy and Industrial
strategy the sectors take for the
environment food and Rural Affairs the
office of the chief medical officer the
United Kingdom Health Security Agency
NHS England
the government office for science
the association of directors of Public
Health Imperial College of Science and
Technology
represented legally together the local
government Association and the Welsh
local government Association the
National Police Chiefs Council Scottish
ministers Public Health Scotland NHS
National Services Scotland the Welsh
government public health Wales the
executive office of Northern Ireland the
Northern Ireland Department of Health
the trades Union Congress the TUC and
the British Medical Association the BMA
my lady co-participant status brings of
course significant procedural advantages
core participants get access to the
disclosed documents they will get to
make submissions on the course and
mechanics of your inquiry
they will get to raise specific
questions and assist you in ensuring
that the inquiry can discharge the
formidable duties imposed upon it
may I say something straight away about
those duties so that there is no doubt
that Duty as you have explained it is to
get to the truth
to ensure that the full facts are
revealed
that culpable and discredible conduct is
exposed and brought to public notice
that plainly wrongful decision-making
and significant errors of judgment are
identified
and that lessons may be properly learned
the bereaved and those who have suffered
are absolutely entitled to no less
the extent of the collaborative approach
required between the inquiry and the
core participants and in particular the
bereaved groups is an issue that has
been raised before you in the written
submissions and it is important that I
address it now
in deference to the importance of the
role that the brewery families for
justice organizations play and your
stated wish that the inquiry Foster and
atmosphere inclusion there has been
extensive communication already between
you your team and those groups
even before the turns of reference were
finalized the inquiry team was working
closely with all the brewery families
for justice organizations and I know my
lady that you are grateful for their
assistance in the terms of reference
consultation exercise that took place in
March when you met bereavee families
across the United Kingdom
the views they shared including on
issues like DNA aprs do not attempt to
cardiopulmonary resuscitation decisions
and end-of-life Care informed your
recommendations for changes to be made
to the scope of this inquiry
all of which proposals the then prime
minister accepted
we have also had a number of meetings
there has been some small disappointment
expressed from one quarter that the
inquiry team did not add to the agenda
items proposed by some of the groups for
those meetings but may I say that the
agendas were only provided shortly
before the meetings but in any event we
were and remain completely happy to be
guided by them as to what they wished to
raise with us
there have also been multiple calls and
a significant amount of Correspondence
indeed the solicitor to your inquiry
Mr Martin Smith has engaged with the
brief families for justice groups more
than with any other core participant and
I should also observe that they've
benefited from your 28th of March 22
decision to Grant legal costs in
connection with the consultation process
they've also received a section 40
determination to cover costs from the
28th of July immediately after module 1
had been opened
so may I also make clear that the
inquiry team is genuinely grateful for
all the contributions from them and for
the other core participants both before
this hearing and in the written
submissions
frankly
in this unprecedented and vast and
difficult undertaking the inquiry team
needs the insightful and sensible
assistance of all the core participants
a list my lady of the Corp participants
that you have designated will of course
be published on the website in due
course
turning to the written arguments which
have been produced for this morning
my lady as you know you've had notes
from myself and Miss Blackwell assisted
by the very able Junior Council team
that help us as well as from Mr Smith
sent out in advance of the preliminary
hearing
the inquiry has received eight written
submissions in response one of which is
a joint node submitted on behalf of
covid-19 bereave families of justice and
Northern Ireland covid-19 Brewery
families for justice
the majority of the remainder of the
core participants have kindly indicated
that they don't wish to make oral
submissions and have not filed written
submissions the written submissions have
obviously all been circulated around the
core participants
so my lady what I propose to do is to
say something about the background to
the inquiry it's commencement and
procedures
so as to illuminate and highlight the
issues which arise for ventilation today
I don't propose to answer all the points
made in the written submissions I'll
reserve my position in respect of some
or all of them until they've been
developed by the Corp participants in
their oral submissions
my lady the inquiry understands that
eight of the core participants before
you want to make oral submissions so
after my opening remarks you will of
course be hearing from them following a
speaking order that you've had drawn up
to Aid
the better recollection if it be needed
at all
of the devastating impact of the
covid-19 pandemic
and to reinforce the utter seriousness
and extent of this inquiry's task
it's necessary to set out the briefest
of chronologies of the early stages of
the pandemic
for many including some here today they
will never be forgotten but it is
remarkable how the passage of time
we have allowed some of those terrible
details to be forgotten
my lady as your opening statement
recalled in late December 19.
a cluster of cases of pneumonia of an
unknown etiology was detected in Wuhan
city Hubei Province in China
a new strain of coronavirus was
subsequently isolated on the 7th of
January
it was identified as severe acute
respiratory syndrome coronavirus II SARS
cov2
on the 21st of January the World Health
Organization published its novel
coronavirus
2019 n kovi situation report 1.
it's recorded that as of the 20th of
January
282 confirmed cases of 2019 n Cove had
been reported from four countries
including China Thailand Japan and the
Republic of Korea
on the 30th of January
the second meeting of the international
Health regulations emergency Committee
of the wild Health Organization declared
a public health emergency of
international concern
but it didn't recommend any travel or
trade restrictions
the virus and its Associated disease
covid-19 spread rapidly
on the 15th of February France recorded
the first official death in Europe from
covid-19
by late February the number of cases of
covid-19 outside China had increased 13
fold and the number of affected
countries have tripled
a worldwide Public Health Emergency
ensued and on the 11th of March the
World Health Organization declared covid
to be the first coronavirus pandemic
foreign
will be unaware
covid-19 has killed millions of people
worldwide and infected many millions
more
as of the 20th of September of this year
over 609 million confirmed cases of
covid-19 including around six and a half
million deaths
had been reported to the World Health
Organization
some estimates of death
put the figure for estimated deaths
from covid-19 at 17 and a half million
the pandemic has led to financial and
economic turmoil
it has disrupted economies and education
systems and put unprecedented pressure
on National Health Systems
jobs and businesses have been destroyed
and livelihoods taken away
communities especially the poor and the
vulnerable have been devastated and
existing inequalities have been widened
and exacerbated
the disease has caused widespread and
long-term physical mental illness grief
an Untold misery
its impact will be felt worldwide
including in the United Kingdom for
decades to come
as everyone here will recall
on Monday the 23rd of March of 2020
the then prime minister announced severe
restrictions on the entirety of the
United Kingdom in what became known as
the first national lockdown
my lady I don't propose to say more
about the events leading up to that
cataclysmic moment in the life of this
nation
because for this preliminary hearing
it's not required and they detail
whether in any event be a matter for you
of course to determine
but vast ways of human and social
activity were ordered to be curtailed
and much of public life halted
almost every area of public life across
all four nations including schools the
transport system the justice system
prisons the majority of Public Services
we're all adversely affected Hospitality
retail travel and tourism arts and
culture and the report and Leisure
sectors effectively ceased to operate
even places of worship closed
whilst the number of deaths Rose the NHS
the police and emergency services and
other key workers continued in their
pieces of work
almost everyone else was forced to work
or be educated from home
the months and years that followed
saw death and illness on an
unprecedented scale
recent figures calculate that in England
there have been 165
806 deaths within 28 days of a positive
test
or 171
764 deaths where covid-19
was recorded on the death certificate
the office of national statistics
provides weekly figures for deaths that
are so registered
in Scotland the figures are no less
terrible
twelve thousand three hundred and eighty
nine and fifteen thousand five hundred
and fifty five by those two measures as
of the 4th of September in Wales
7844 and 10
675 and in Northern Ireland
3445 and 4832
by an alternative measure of excess
deaths or excess mortality
that is to say the number of deaths from
all causes above and beyond what would
be expected under normal conditions I
had the pandemic not occurred so
capturing not only confirmed deaths but
also covid-19 deaths that were not
correctly diagnosed or reported as well
as deaths from other causes
attributable to the pandemic
the figures are likely to be higher
still
beyond the individual tragedy of each
and every death
is clear the pandemic placed
extraordinary levels of strain on the
UK's Health Care financial and
Educational Systems as well as our jobs
and businesses
it affected the health and well-being of
vast numbers of people particularly
vulnerable groups including people with
disabilities
the clinically vulnerable the mentally
ill essay minority groups older people
children
and those living into private areas
cost in human and financial terms of
bringing coronavirus under control
has my lady
been immense
government borrowing and the cost of
procurement and of the various job
retention income loan sick pay and other
support schemes have severely impacted
public finances and our Financial Health
concern has been expressed from many
quarters that poor health and existing
inequalities have left part to United
Kingdom more vulnerable to to the
disease
and that the restrictions imposed on the
country have led to unmet health needs
damaged educational prospects and
financial insecurity
societal damage has been widespread
with existing inequalities exacerbated
and access to opportunity significantly
weakened
the impact on the NHS its operations its
waiting lists and elective care has been
similarly immense
so my lady this inquiry has been
constituted to investigate on behalf of
the bereaved and those who have
otherwise suffered as well as the wider
public
whether anything could have been done
more to prevent their loss or reduce
their suffering
more specifically in this module they
are entitled to know
whether the United Kingdom and its
citizens for preparedness and response
could have been better
only in this way
as you have said
can proper and effective recommendations
be drawn up to protect the country
better
from pandemics whether caused by Future
coronavirus variants or some other forms
of disease
and also from comparable civil
emergencies
given the sheer extent of the impact of
the pandemic and the government decision
making that was required across such a
very wide range of areas it is little
surprise that this inquiry will be no
less complex and multifaceted
may I therefore turn to say something
about the commencement of the inquiry so
there's legal foundations and scope can
be properly understood and the work that
has already been done brought to public
attention
on the 12th of May
the then prime minister made a statement
in the House of Commons in which he
announced there would be a public
inquiry under the inquiries Act 2005.
on the 15th of December as the
sponsoring Minister he appointed you my
lady as chair
in the written appointment letter the
Prime Minister confirmed that he'd be
Consulting with ministers from the
default Administrations
such consultation is required by section
27 of the inquiries Act 2005.
to enable the inclusion in the terms of
reference of an inquiry for which United
Kingdom Minister including the prime
minister is responsible
of anything that would require the
inquiry to determine facts and make
recommendations holy or primarily
concerned with a Scottish matter or a
Welsh matter or a transferred Northern
Ireland matter
draft terms of reference were drawn up
making clear that the inquiry would
consider and report on the state's
preparations and response to the
pandemic and would consider reserved and
evolved matters in those nations in
respect of which there had been a need
for such consultation
on the 10th of January you wrote to the
Prime Minister recommending certain
amendments to ensure greater Clarity and
to enable you to conduct the inquiry at
an appropriate pace
you also sought an Express mandate
permitting the publication of interim
reports
in addition
importantly given your view that the
inquiry would gain greater public
confidence and help the nation to come
to terms of the pandemic
if it was open to the accounts that many
people would wish to give you suggested
adding explicit acknowledgment of the
need to hear about people's experiences
and to consider any disparities the
impact of the pandemic
on the 4th of February the Prime
Minister responded accepting that some
minor irrelevant changes or minor
caveats and a small number of textual
refinements the detailed changes that
you had proposed
on the 10th of March having consulted
with the ministers from the divorce
administrations and the way that I've
described he wrote you to inform you of
certain further changes which had been
made in response to their comments
the same day the draft tons of reference
were published
you then wrote an open letter to the
public in which you announced the launch
of a public consultation process on the
draft terms of reference
the consultation document saw the
Public's views on whether the inquiries
draft terms of reference covered all the
errors that they thought should be
addressed and on whether the inquiry
should set a planned end date
the consultation was open to everyone
and the public could contribute on the
inquiries website by email or by writing
you consulted widely across all four
nations visiting towns and cities across
England Wells Scotland Northern Ireland
and speaking in particular to a number
of the briefed in parallel your team met
with the representatives of more than
150 organizations in Roundtable
discussions covering themes such as
equality and diversity Healthcare
business and education and young people
among many
in total
you received over 20 000 responses to
the consultation
an independent consultancy team was
commissioned to analyze the responses
they produced a comprehensive report
summarizing those views and the key
themes that emerged
and so in light of that process and the
many thousands of views expressed you
recommended a number of further changes
to the draft terms of reference
you wrote asking that those changes be
made
they were all accepted in full
and so on the 21st of July The Inquirer
was formally opened and you announced
the decision to conduct the inquiry in
modules
this module concerns of course
resilience and preparedness prior to the
pandemic but I need to say just a little
bit more about the overall width of the
inquiry to show that this module forms
only one part of it
module two
the provisional outline of its scope was
published on the 31st of August
it will look essentially at the core
political and administrative governance
and decision-making in the United
Kingdom concerning the high-level
response to the pandemic from January
2020 onwards
it will pay particular scrutiny to the
decisions taken by the Prime Minister
and the cabinet as advised by the Civil
Service senior political scientific and
medical advisors
as well as relevant cabinet
subcommittees
it will examine government structures
and bodies concerned with the response
the initial understanding and response
to the nature and spread of covid the
government's initial strategies
the decision-making relating to the
non-pharmaceutical interventions
the national lockdowns
the restrictions the circuit breakers
the working from home the orders to
reduce person-to-person contact social
distancing and so on
but also their timeliness and
reasonableness including the likely
effects had decisions to intervene being
taken earlier or differently
importantly
the degree to which the government
looked at and considered
the risk on vulnerable groups and others
access to and use in decision making of
medical and scientific expertise data
collection of modeling Public Health
Communications
in relation to steps taken to control
the spread of the virus the transparency
of government messaging the use of
Behavioral Management and the
maintenance of public confidence
all those as I say are for module two
inquiry is obliged under Section 27 of
the inquiries act as well as its terms
of reference as I've said to consider
both reserved and evolved matters in
respect of Scotland Wells and Northern
Ireland
so having considered the picture in
module 2 from a UK wide and also English
perspective modules 2A 2B and 2C will
address the same overarching and
strategic issues from the perspectives
of Scotland Wells and Northern Ireland
but obviously on account of the fact
that an inquiry has been established in
Scotland to look at matters devolved to
the Scottish government your intention
in relation to Scottish matters has been
to seek to minimize any duplication that
might arise and so a memorandum of
understanding is already under
discussion to guide both inquiries in
their Communications with document
providers
potential Witnesses and other sources of
information material to ensure the
minimum degree of overlap
module three
it will examine the impact of covid and
the governmental responses on the Health
Care Systems generally across the United
Kingdom
it'll investigate the general impact of
the pandemic on the healthcare system's
governance hospitals Primary Care
NHS one-on-one services and ambulance
services it'll address issues such as
the use of do not resuscitate orders the
rationing of critical care capacity
triage systems the shielding and care of
the extremely vulnerable NHS backlogs
and waiting times and the treatment of
those suffering from long covert
later details
at later modules details of which will
be published in the coming months will
address very broadly system and impact
issues across the United Kingdom
vaccines Therapeutics the care sector
government procurement and PPE testing
Trace government financial responses
the impact modules will look at Health
inequalities and the impact of covert on
the education of business sectors
children and young persons on public
services and another public sectors
hence my lady the unprecedented and
ambitious nature of this inquiry
module one scope
the document setting out the provisional
outline of scope for this module has
been published on the inquiry website
and I do propose to read it out
the outline of scope document was
expressly designed to be provisional so
that the core participants could see
that they were being invited to comment
on its further development as indeed
they have
in essence the module is concerned with
high-level pandemic resilience
preparedness and planning across all
four nations
it will examine whether the correct
structures bodies procedures and
policies were in place at UK and at
Regional National levels and look at
their history development cooperation
and performance
in terms of inquiring to pandemic
planning
this will include examination of the
forecasting processes
the extent to which past knowledge of
actual events and simulated exercises
were learned from
the degree of Readiness preparation and
the general resources that were
available
International comparisons will be drawn
and the funding capacity and maintenance
of emergency planning and public health
structures examined this will include
any impact arising from the United
Kingdom's departure from the European
Union
evidence will be given in relation to
the planning for future pandemics
including the forecasting of new
covid-19 variants
other viruses are concerned and diseases
resulting from viral transmission from
animals
but that scope my lady although it
introduces a wide range of areas
cannot at this stage be readily
determined in detail it's neither
practical nor available advisable to
identify now all the granular issues
that will be addressed at the module one
hearing let alone the questions that
will arise forensically
concern has been expressed by one core
participant that the scope of module one
has been Limited in some way but the
wording of the decision letter in the
case of that corporate participant
granted core participant status
may I see therefore that the reasoning
in that letter did not and could not
purport to reflect the entirety of the
module 1 scope
so my lady the issues will obviously be
further developed once the responses to
the majority of the rule 9 requests for
evidence have been received and analyzed
but a number of very helpful suggestions
have been made by the core participants
concerning scoop by way of identifying
changes in the direction or specifying
particular areas for investigation in
module one and I know my lady that we
you and the team will would wish to
reflect on them all
but now I just make a number of points
as to how we propose to do so
we will
approach those suggestions from the core
participants with an open Indeed ego
frame of mind
it serves absolutely no purpose
whatsoever
for us to expand the time energy and
cost in designing and holding a module
one public hearing only for issues of
real importance not to be explored
secondly this is only the first module
it is designed to investigate the
general state of the United Kingdom's
resilience and preparedness all that
thereof
it cannot be used as a vehicle to front
load other issues better suited for
scrutiny later in the inquiry
that scope document is meant only to be
a generic guide as I've said the actual
scope and the issues and questions that
will arise for scrutiny
will be far better assessed by reference
to the forensic troll that is this
process of gathering up documents
statements and information
from core participants
from evidence providers holders of
documents and many many more entities
that process is designed to sweep up a
significant body of documents and
statements from which the issues can
then be identified and developed
and lastly my lady as you said in your
opening statement in July and again
today with such a wide scope
the inquiry needs to be ruthless in its
selection of issues and Relentless in
its focus on matters of real importance
it is simply not possible to examine
every issue even if thematically within
the reach of module one or to call every
witness relating to every event issue or
major decision
what is instead required is a carefully
judged assessment of what really matters
I've mentioned the rule 9 requests
may I say a little more about them
so since the start
the startup date of the 21st of July
huge amount of work has been done in
terms of resourcing and Staffing the
inquiry setting up the legal teams
identifying hearing venues responding to
public Communications and setting this
module on its way
the inquiry is also identified and
published the scope documents the
outline of scope documents as I've said
in relation to modules two two a through
to 2C
it's also prepared the groundwork for
the later modules which will follow in
quick succession and there is also then
the listening exercise
but importantly the inquiry has already
issued formal requests for evidence
pursuant to rule 9 of the inquiry rules
to the following organizations which
appear to us to have played a central or
significant role in relation to the
United Kingdom's resilience planning and
preparedness the cabinet office the
department for leveling up housing and
communities and the Department of Health
and Social care
my lady those rule nines are lengthy
complex and wide-ranging
their request information and documents
including policy documents genders
meeting notes minutes
and the identities of key figures and
decision makers including ministers
civil servants and advisers
relating to relevant decision-making on
preparedness between June
2009 when the World Health Organization
announced the scientific criteria had
been met for an influenza pandemic for
what became known as the swine flu
pandemic
and January 2020 the 21st in fact the
date upon which the World Health
Organization published its novel
coronavirus situation report number one
the areas of inquiry
range widely
they have been made or the inquiries by
where rule 9 to be made in relation to
development and functions of relevant
organizations resources and levels of
funding the monitoring and communication
of new and emerging infectious diseases
the duties and responsibilities under
the Civil contingencies act 2004
policies and operational strategy
including those set out in various
pandemic preparedness strategy documents
and reports
we have sought explanation and Analysis
of the government's forecasting of
influenza and high consequence
infectious diseases of institutional
learning and the simulated and real
exercises from exercise winter Willow in
2007 through to exercise Pica in 2018.
we have sought information relating to
Public Health services and resources to
stockpiling essential resources
cooperation between government and of
all administration's Regional local
government and expert advisory groups
and public sector bodies
we've sought the disclosure of key
actions activities initiative policies
and publications
in the next few weeks
rule 9 requests will also be sent to the
United Kingdom Health Security Agency
his Majesty's treasury the Welsh
government the government's Northern
Ireland and the Scottish government
the trades Union Congress has helpfully
suggested adding the health and safety
safety executive and we will reflect on
that
the rule nine requests are being issued
on an iterative basis
part of which further requests will then
be made to the recipients focusing on
particular issues or topics
we will then issue further real nine
requests on a rolling basis to other
organizations
some have asked in their written
submissions whether we will disclose the
rule 9 requests themselves the requests
made of all those various entities
in my submission my lady that is however
neither required by the rules more
established by past practice
it is we suggest furthermore not
practicable
given that all almost all the rule nine
requests will be superseded
and built upon by further iterative
requests from the choir team itself
disclosure of each rule 9 request
serves we we suggest no purpose
some core participants have raised the
issue of position statements by state
bodies and organizations
so my lady the proposition before you in
some of the written submissions is that
position statements if ordered would
assist you by enabling you to Target
further disclosure hone the expert
evidence and tailor the hearings to
those areas that are actually in dispute
or are unclear
we suggest with respect however that the
foundational principle that this
argument is based upon may not be
correct in the circumstances of this
inquiry
you will of course be reflecting on all
the submissions but may I introduce a
note of caution
foreign
statements are in effect a form of
pleading but they're not required and
they're not required they're not a
required feature of inquiry proceedings
which are of course not adversarial
in any event we rather doubt whether
such statements would help to narrow
issues and therefore save time and cost
written clarification of a document
provider's position whether in a
position statement or otherwise can
really only be done
at a point when that entity is
sufficiently cited on the issues the
disclosure that enables their proper
examination and their own position
so to start the inquiry process for the
position statement is to jump the gun
asking entities to commit to a committed
position at an early stage is therefore
liable to lead to delay in the
commencement of the process
because in this
complex forensic picture it's likely to
take months for them to be able to
assemble sufficient documentation for
them to identify their position then
form it and then commit to an
inalienable position on paper
foreign
this inquiry is in truth an inquiry into
Myriad decisions and complex decision
making
it's not an inquiry into an easily
identifiable event or action
as to which document providers and
decision makers might be expected to
have a pellucid position
it's not inquiry limited by a single
event a short passage of time a place or
a limited course of government or state
conduct a crash air crash an explosion
shootings or a single terrorist attack
nor is it limited by place as with the
sizeable inquiry or the inquiry into the
British role Infirmary Hospital or by
connection to a person
or even a particular decisional policy
or course of behavior such as the
infected blood inquiry or the post
office Horizon inquiry
you will be scrutinizing
government decision making made by a
very significant number of bodies and
individuals over many years even in this
module a complex and multi-layered task
and therefore it simply doesn't readily
lend itself to the preparation of
position statements
but may I say
that you know my lady that you will and
you've already started seeking corporate
witness statements as well as making
those more directive requests of which
I've spoken
and those demons will naturally reflect
the particular entity's position but
they will have a far better Foundation
I then turn to disclosure
there is no Express requirement for
disclosure contained in the acts or the
rules
the reason why of course inquiries give
disclosure is because it arises that the
obligation arises from your overarching
obligation to act fairly under Section
17 3 of the act and core participants
must have disclosure of relevant
documents in advance of the public
hearing to enable them to contribute
meaningfully to the process
plainly
to make sure that the inquiry is in a
position to disclose relevant material
we will be casting our net more widely
when Gathering it in
the inquiry does this by asking document
providers for material that is likely to
be relevant to the issues that will
arise in the course of the module
therefore
it is neither necessary nor
proportionate
for the inquiry to disclose every
document that it receives or every
request that it makes or every piece of
Correspondence
that is not required and it would hinder
the inquiry and performance of its
functions
in particular the documents received
from document providers can't be
provided without that sift for relevancy
and for utility
it would be a derogation of the
inquiries functions to Simply pass
everything on to the core participants
but may I say that as an inquiry team we
will of course be giving regular
disclosure updates in which we can
report on the progress which has been
made
we don't propose only to provide core
participants with documents relevant to
them
all Court core participants will receive
the same documents for the particular
module
third will provide all relevant
documents that the inquiries received
subject to a deduplication exercise and
appropriate redactions in accordance
with the redactions protocol
but lastly we don't propose to provide a
document protocol I have set out our
general approach and the provision of
protocols for protocol's sake assist no
one
a lady it's likely that we'll be making
disclosure in tranches rather than uh by
way as opposed to documents being made
available as soon as they are provided
to us
and lastly some core participants have
requested that document providers sign a
statement explaining how they've secured
the preservation of documents how
they've conducted their own searches and
how they have satisfied themselves that
they've complied and filled with their
duties
I can say that each provider has been
asked or will be asked to provide an
account sending out details of how the
documents were originally stored the
Search terms used or other processes
used to locate documents and the nature
of any review carried out by them
where we have queries or concerns about
those procedures we will raise them and
we will pursue them and of course as
documents are disclosed and gaps
identified we will seek further
documents
I should also observe that the inquiry
is also already taken steps to ensure
the preservation of documents
on the 20th of January the secretary to
the inquiry Mr Ben Connor
wrote
to the director General propriety and
ethics of the cabinet office to request
the retention of Records across the
entirety of the government
on the 8th of February the director
General replied setting out the steps
that have been taken to ensure records
relevant to the inquiry were being
retained across the whole of government
there are also Provisions in section 35
the inquiries act which make it an
offense
if any person does anything to alter or
distort a relevant document or prevent
any relevant document being produced to
the inquiry or intentionally destroys
suppresses or conceals a relevant
document
lastly on this topic
some core participants seek an
obligation
or they seek from you
the provisioner of a list of undisclosed
documents that is to say documents which
we the inquiry will not be providing to
the core participants
it is of course a matter for you and you
will reflect on that submission but we
ask rhetorically to what end
it is for the inquiry to determine
whether proper disclosure is being made
whether further areas are required to be
explored and whether there are more
documents required to be produced
the production of a document setting out
everything that has not been disclosed
would simply require an immense amount
of further work to little end
no final decision has been taken as to
which electronic disclosure system will
be operated by the inquiry to provide
those documents to core participants
we anticipate my lady the disclosure
will commence Before Christmas
again a topic that has fallen within the
scope of the written submissions which
have been provided today
the inquiry will obviously review and
provide a vast amount of national and
international research material relating
to pandemic preparedness and make that
material available
a significant number of qualified
experts and persons with recognized
expertise are also likely to be giving
evidence that the public hearing as
Witnesses of fact
however the inquiry will also appoint
qualified experts in particular fields
of expertise as experts to the inquiry
they will assess the inquiry either
individually or as part of a group of
such persons by way of written reports
and opinions and where appropriate the
giving of oral evidence at the
subsequent public hearing
they will naturally have the appropriate
expertise and experience for the
particular instruction
and they will be selected on the grounds
of their independence and objectivity
the identification however of suitable
experts is not at all straightforward
given the public ventilation by many of
them of the areas of expertise in which
they practice the fact that many of them
were in the world themselves involved in
the events under investigation
and the fact that there is a distinct
lack of unanimity on many matters
but we've already compiled a list of
provisionally suitable experts for
module one
their reports when prepared will
naturally be shared with the core
participants and they will be published
on the inquiries website
where there are significant differences
of view or emphasis among members of a
group they will be made clear on the
face of the reports and of course can be
tested during the public hearing
my lady we set out in the note from
cancel to the inquiry a number of
specialist topics on which the
assistance of expert witnesses will be
sought for module one I I don't propose
to read them out
but they cover such errors as the
identification history and funding of
those structures and bodies at
government devolved Administration and
local Authority level concerned with
risk management the changes to those
structures and bodies their funding
their resourcing
the identification of international
bodies concerned with risk management
and the comparative examination of their
performance with our own
the identification history and funding
of UK Public Health bodies their
development over time their Readiness
and preparation and also forecasting of
epidemic Trends and the transmission of
diseases
may I express my gratitude to those
called participants who have already
expressed interest in that topic and and
have offered other suitable areas for
exploration and we're particularly
grateful to the Department of Health in
Northern Ireland for its early
assistance in relation to the
identification of potential experts
but my lady the guiding principle must
remain it has been inquiry to
investigate the appointment of experts
and the final decision of course on who
they will be is absolutely a matter for
you
the letters of instruction setting out
the parameters of their work and the
questions for their consideration will
be prepared and the questions that they
will be asked to address will be made
available to court participants in
advance of the reports being finalized
so that Corp participants will be
provided with an opportunity to provide
observations on them
then turned to the listening exercise a
vital part of your inquiry
as foreshadowed in the terms of
reference that you recommended and which
were accepted
the inquiry is designing and setting up
a process by which the experiences of
bereaved families and others who have
suffered hardship or loss as a result of
the pandemic
will be submitted
and listened to or read
and then analyzed and summarized
before being provided to the inquiry
teams and the core participants for use
in the public hearings
this will allow the inquiry to
understand the experiences of the
pandemic
from across the whole United Kingdom
including those most affected
and those whose voices are not always
had
it will provide an opportunity
for people to tell us about their
experiences without the formality of
giving evidence or attending a public
hearing
the process my lady will reach vastly
more people than could ever be
accommodated but the giving of witness
evidence in a public hearing
so the listening exercise will hear or
receive accounts
from a broad range of people including
the bereaved and those whose Health has
suffered from the disease those living
with disability or health problems that
clinically vulnerable and those whose
Family Life education jobs health and
well-being and livelihoods have been
significantly affected
those summaries
and the accompanying analysis not just
data and numbers will be fed into the
public hearings as written evidence and
informed the inquiry's understanding
my lady this is scarcely
marginalization of those who have
suffered
the details of the current plans have
been set out in a note from Mr Martin
Smith and that will be shortly available
be shortly available on the website
but I need to emphasize that
that massive information needs to be
properly assimilated and understood
if it is to prove the worth that we
expected to be
it is designed this process
to take the accounts from tens or
possibly hundreds of thousands of people
and bearing in mind the importance to
the inquiries architecture of that
process
and to ensure its robust and easy for
anyone who wishes to participate in
the listening exercise will take some
time to design and test
but the procurement of specialist
assistance is underway
as part of that work
your inquiry Milady will start trialling
different approaches for the listening
exercise shortly
that will include later this year an
online platform which will invite people
to share their experiences and then
later in the winter and in the spring
targeted face-to-face sessions with some
selected groups from society
over time the trials will develop an
increase in scale until the exercise is
running at full capacity
so that process
is an integral part of the inquiries
process
that evidence
will necessarily be anonymized how could
it not be
there will be no need for legal
representation for the participation and
it's not intended inquiry will fund
legal assistance
but the material which comes from that
exercise will go to the heart
of the inquiries procedures
some of the core participants have asked
perfectly properly
some questions about the process who
will be doing the listening what
qualifications of any will the listeners
have what training will they have how
will the experiences be recorded
this is naturally all to be worked out
but my lady may I say for the benefit of
those listening that a great deal of
time energy and resource has already
been devoted to ensuring proper correct
answers to those questions
are made
may I then turn to commemoration
given the scale of the loss and hardship
the inquiry wishes to provide
opportunities for this to be
commemorated as part of the inquiries
process
so the inquiry team intends to create a
physical installation in its future
Hearing Center which could be a static
or mobile artwork or a more organic
piece that grows over time
a book of commemoration or a video wall
it's also looking as how the inquiry
website can be used for proper
commemoration
my lady your team is already working on
this to find the right solution and it
has already reached out to the
representatives of those most affected
to develop a commemoration that is
suitable and captures the right feelings
and emotions
and then the sensitive and difficult
issue of the evidence of individual
deaths and Pen portrait evidence
paragraph B
of the terms of reference by which the
inquiry is bound
provides that the inquiry will not
consider in detail individual cases of
harm or death
that is
because my lady the core function of
this inquiry is not to inquire into the
direct circumstances
of the tragic deaths that occurred
but is instead to examine the pandemic
that led to those deaths and the
response of the pandemic in order to
ensure that in future death and
suffering and harm cannot occur on such
a scale again
so it is necessarily an inquiry into
high-level decision making and systemic
issues and failures
moreover
given the breadth of the inquiries remit
and the need to make timely
recommendations about the pandemic the
receipt of oral evidence that public
hearings about individuals losses or the
circumstances of individual deaths
is impracticable
it would also require the most invidious
of decisions
amongst the hundreds of thousands of
deaths
who should be called upon to give
evidence
but as you have said
and I emphasized again
that is not to say there will not be
evidence from individuals
surrounding the circumstances of the
deaths of loved ones as part of the
later modules in relation to the
circumstances leading up to death the
use of do not resuscitate orders you
have mentioned
but also there are any number of issues
which may be illuminated by the giving
of individual evidence but only because
it's relevant to the systemic flaws that
that we believe may have existed so
evidence relating to the NHS 111 system
or the triage system or Mortuary
arrangements or end-of-life care are all
wider issues to which such evidence May
well be relevant
the inquiries also received submissions
from bereaved families to Justice groups
asking for extensive pen portrait
evidence to be heard that is to say
statements or other materials such as
videos relating to the lies of the
persons who have died
my lady we recognize the value that this
can bring in an inquest or an inquiry
performing the role of an inquest
and we acknowledge the heartfelt
submissions that have been made as part
of that request
but this too is impractical
it is also not required by the European
convention on human rights because of
course effective participation
is a procedural guarantee which doesn't
prescribe the introduction of any
particular forensic material by a
specific route
but far more importantly
as it happens
the listening exercise that you have
ordered to be undertaken will be a far
more extensively developed process by
which individuals may have their
accounts heard and considered
but lastly in any event
may I say that you've also asked that
consideration be given to alternative
ways in which individual tragedies can
be publicly but briefly recognized in
the module hearings there will be more
on that and on
so
my lady before you hear from the league
of Representatives of the core
participants who wish to make oral
submissions
may I conclude by saying that there will
be a further preliminary hearing for
module one early in 2023 in London on a
specific date and venue to be confirmed
and it may be that a third preliminary
hearing will be required but it is
simply too early to say
the public Hearing in this module
will take place in London in May 2023
it will provisionally last four weeks
but as with every aspect of this hearing
process
it will be kept onto review
notice will be given of everything that
is required to be so notified
it may not always allow as much time as
the core participants would like
I'm sorry for that we will do our best
but time is against us there is a huge
amount to be done
and the final point my lady concerns
more prosaically the section 40
determinations
on the subject of those applications
some have already been received but more
can be expected from the core
participants who are not amongst the
bereaved family groups who have not yet
made them may we invite you to ask that
those applications be filed but perhaps
within 14 days
my lady that concludes my opening
remarks
thank you very much Mr Keith I've been
asked to take a break for the benefit as
the sonographers or transcribers so um I
shall return at 11 30. thank you very
much
right Mr Weatherby
oh you're there well then
good morning
um I represent the uh covid bereaved
families for justice Group which came
into being soon after the pandemic
struck our Shores and were set up as a
campaigning Group by those who had lost
loved ones to covert and what they
perceived as the lack of preparedness
and response to it
started as a Facebook group and it
currently has more than six and a half
thousand supporters
some
3225 of whom
have signed up as members of the group
which simply means that they have a
greater involvement as part of it
the membership is spread across England
Scotland Wales and Northern Ireland
and the group is very much a UK wide one
it's administratively organized as a
limited company with directors who are
all buried family members
Brody Jackson cancer are instructed for
the Kobe brief families for justice
group
and alkan abrahamson is the recognized
legal representative for the inquiry and
I lead the central Council team
how many members of those who died in
the devil Nations and jurisdictions have
organized into branches
we have a fully collaborative
arrangement with the Northern Ireland
families and the Northern Ireland legal
team
but there's a difference of view with
some of the families in Scotland and
Wales which the group and the families
are currently trying to resolve and it
appears that there may be the emergence
of some autonomous groups as well
the covered Brewery families for justice
group campaign for this inquiry and for
devolved inquiries right from its
Inception
for a long time the government resisted
but eventually as Mr Keith has already
said
in May of last year the former PM
announced that there would be a
statutory inquiry
he did so at a time that the families
through the uh Kobe Brie families for
justice had indicated that they were to
pursue due to judicial review
proceedings if he did not
is already public knowledge
but I make it clear now to demonstrate
just how much the families want this
process to succeed and their intention
to participate effectively within it
from the announcement in May of last
year there was then a further delay of
eight months in appointing you as chair
and more delay in providing draft terms
of reference and then informally setting
up the inquiry in June of this year
the resistance in exceeding to an
inquiry in the first place and the
subsequent delays have caused
substantial frustration to the families
and their wish to expedite the inquiry
in order to try to prevent future deaths
in particular by the time the
recommendations that may follow from the
modules that you've announced
however within the period from when you
were appointed the families recognized
that you instituted the consultation on
the terms of reference indeed the very
same day the draft was provided to you
by the Prime Minister your Council has
already noted
that the consultation involved
face-to-face meetings with the breathed
in I think 11 locations
but what is perhaps also worth noting is
that those meetings were facilitated by
the Kobe breed families for justice
group and indeed I think all of the
families that you met
were part of the group at that time
it's clear from the recommendations made
to the prime minister
that you took account of many of the
views expressed to you from the bereave
directly
and indeed from submissions made on
behalf of the group in writing at that
time which followed those consultations
and again I mentioned all of this as it
demonstrates that the inquiry well
understood from the outset the
importance of the bereaved and their
effective participation in the process
they are of course by no means the only
persons or groups with a keen interest
in this process and I readily
acknowledge that however they are front
and Central to it
and again the consultation indicates the
clear commitment of the group and the
families to collaborate in ensuring the
inquiry reaches its goals the importance
of hearing directly
firsthand from the bereaved is a theme
of course I will return to in due course
however
as you know from our written submissions
and prefaced by Mr Keith helpfully this
morning we have raised concerns about
the engagement of the inquiry with the
Kobe brief funds for justice team since
the consultation we've attempted to
engage in writing in submissions on the
1st of April regarding process and in
particular regarding the evidence of the
breeds themselves on the 30th of June
and through requests for information
about the intentions of the inquiry
regarding for example the central matter
of importance at the moment to the
families
um the listening exercise
but likewise the provisional scope of
module one was handed down without any
real discussion about what it might
include
now of course we recognize we can and we
will make submissions about both issues
today
but our collective experience is set out
in the written submissions is that much
more can be achieved by dialogue a
two-way street between the teams prior
to positions hardening documents being
published and decisions being set up by
the inquiry in in writing
there's been reference by Mr Keith this
morning
um to the fact that there has been
extensive
um contact between the teams that most
certainly has I do not wish to be
misunderstood here and I do not suggest
that we have a poor relationship with
your team we don't
um we want to make it work
they have as far as my recollection is
concerned we've had four meetings with
your team
uh Mr Keith has indicated there's a
willingness to discuss what we raise
with respect that is an identification
of the point I make
we seek a two-way street
we seek the inquiry to come to us as
well as us coming to the inquiry to
discuss important matters which either
directly Engage The bereaved or which
the bereaved have a central position in
trying to assist the inquiry for example
the scope of the modules and what should
be included and that does with the
greatest of respect identify the problem
that this idea of dialogue has to come
from both sides and to some degree that
is what's missing at the moment
I've explained the position of the group
in some detail this morning mindful that
the wider world of media are watching
um to emphasize that we do not want to
be some kind of official opposition
within this inquiry quite the opposite
and neither do we seek special treatment
we don't we have made it consistently
clear
that any dialogue that is had with us
we expect will be had with all of the
other core participants and indeed
others that we perceive is the role of
independent Council and independent
solicitors instructed for the inquiry
that the better dialogue we seek should
be undertaken across the board
I will Undertake from our side to do
everything possible to make that work
the families have no plan B and most
certainly neither do I
and I hope this particular submission is
received in the spirit within which it
is made
on further point before turning to the
agenda items we note that the pm has
still to nominate the panel members who
were promised to assist you in in the
inquiry that we made submissions about
that issue many months ago and how it's
an opportunity to enhance the
decision-making process by expanding the
range of life experience and the
diversity of those rights at the center
of it
and we obviously recognize that this is
a matter of the Prime Minister
but it's a matter directly affecting the
inquiry and its progress and so we would
hope that you would join with us in
asking the PM to resolve that matter
that was promised some 10 months ago
the agenda I'm only going to address the
matters which we want to make
submissions on so if I miss something
it's
because we don't have anything to say at
this point
in respect to module one and we
respectfully commend the fact that
preparedness is the starting point for
the inquiry and that was very much our
position too from the outset and it's
very much the logical place to start and
indeed more than that it may be one of
the key areas whereas the inquiry can
make a real difference and relatively
quickly through recommendations
we do understand that the scope that was
published was provisional in the first
iteration but we've set out in paragraph
eight and following in our written
submissions uh three particular concerns
which we
um do so to assist the inquiry the first
of which is the treatment of devolved
issues within module one
the second is the this proportions
effect of the pandemic on black and
brown communities other ethnic minority
communities and other sections of our
communities who are otherwise more
vulnerable because of personal
characteristics
and thirdly the social care and Care
home sector and places of detention
now it may be on this subject that none
of our submissions on these issues are
too controversial but before I make them
this is again rolling back
um an example of perhaps the way that
dialogue could enhance the process
and if as we move forward if the inquiry
team could
discuss with core participants the scope
of particular modules perhaps with lists
of issues provisional lists of issues
draft lists of issues than the scope
documents are now announced by the
inquiry would be Fuller and all of us
would be actually engaged in that
process
and then the scope for further
submissions would be limited to matters
which are controversial or not agreed or
perhaps Arise at the later point
dealing with three issues briefly with
respect to default issues we don't
understand why a different approach is
being taken in module one as compared
with module two
it appears to us that that only through
dealing with devolved matters in a
dedicated manner can the inquiry ensure
it covers each devolved Nation or
jurisdiction fully
and recognize that each is unique which
we perceive as the approach taken in
module two
and only through undertaking the
analysis in that way then the inquiry be
sure of then determining how the devolve
structures Provisions decisions on
preparedness fitted together with the
overall UK structures Provisions
decisions or indeed that it did not
I know my little friends from the
Northern Ireland team are no doubt
others with respect to Scotland and
Wales will also make submissions on this
point but we simply flag at this point
that we raise a an issue about
understanding how the devolved issues
relating to prepare preparedness will
work on the current thinking on module
one and requests and clarification about
that
um as you'll recall the general issues
of discrimination and the disparity of
effect of the pandemic on certain black
and brown communities and other minority
ethnic communities was raised
persistently during the terms of
reference consultation faced by families
and so too the position of other
vulnerable sections of the community the
elderly those with mental health issues
people living with autism or
developmental disorders those with
clinical vulnerabilities those with
physical disabilities those in detention
and following those concerns you made
recommendations as to the prominence
within the terms of reference with which
those issues should be treated
yet they're not apparent within the
provisional scope for module one and
with respect we think they ought to be
proper preparedness should have fully
included these considerations and the
inquiry should in our respectful
submission investigate why they
apparently did not or did not do a
sufficient degree
pandemics are occasionally said to be
indiscriminate but that is of course not
right age gender race disability
comorbidities are all obvious potential
factors so too our discrimination
disadvantage poverty and the need for
people to remain imposed as key workers
or the existence of the gig economy all
of these are relevant and ought to being
considered in terms of preparedness
those who were responsible for
preparedness should have taken clear
account of discrimination the
differences across communities the fact
that public health and inequality and
social deprivation are linked and the
fact that many different sections of the
communities require different provision
to protect them
and as with the terms of reference we
submit that this should be made clearer
within the scope
of module one
that further and I'll come back to this
very briefly later but um at the moment
um
we
um suggest propose submit
um that the issues of disproportionate
effect and discrimination and their
relation to preparedness is likely to be
an area where you will be assisted
um by expert evidence and that's a
matter that we intend to address you
more fully on in due course the third
point I can put very quickly the
provisional scope makes reference to
Public Health Services into economic
planning
but not to social care or care homes or
indeed places of detention and again we
hope that can be made explicit also
um but again I I make the general point
that it would be helpful if we could
have a dialogue about
um um scope before it's set out in
public
at rule nine and position Stones I'll
deal with these submissions together if
I may
um that paragraph 13 of the written
submissions we've made reference to the
efforts which the inquiry has taken to
date to gather evidence set out in the
council's note for this hearing but very
fully by Mr Keith very helpfully by Mr
Keith earlier today
we've made three points about this
firstly all material providers should be
asked to provide all potentially
relevant material so that the inquiry
can determine the inquiry what is
actually relevant to its investigations
in line with its terms of reference and
the providers should be reminded of
their duty of candor
this may seem a trite and obvious point
but in order for public confidence to be
maintained it must be made clear that
providers in particular public
authorities must take a wide approach
and not tailor disclosure to their own
ends or sit on their hands and only
provide material which has been
expressly requested
I note the efforts to address this in
the detailed rule nines we're told have
been made but in our submission history
shows that this is something which needs
to be made expressly clear and in terms
secondly if um cold partisans are to
effectively participate in evidence
Gathering particularly in an inquiry as
wide-ranging as this and one where we
respectfully command your approach in
driving it Forward quickly
um we submit that the rule 9 request
should be disclosed in order that we can
see not just a summary of a helpful
summary but not just a summary but we
can see what's being requested and it
will allow us to suggest other avenues
or other material that we may just have
spotted which your team may not
um however diligent and effective
um
they are we don't actually think this is
a radical submission
um it's transparent it allows all of us
to collaborate with the inquiry and
progressing its work
expeditiously and it builds confidence
between us
the disclosure would be subject to the
undertakings so we can't see a
difficulty
um in taking this
approach we have flagged this up with
your team in advance which I think may
be why Mr Keith again hopefully
addressed it but we don't think
um well first of all we do think that in
in in the past there have been occasions
where all nines have been disclosed we
can't think of any legal reason or any
practical reason why they shouldn't be
disclosed and therefore we ask you to
consider that submission
um and positively do it the third Point
we've we've raised is in respect to what
have become known as position statements
now position settings can be cast
um as rule nines or otherwise and we
don't in fact think it matters
um but we submit that the inquiry should
request from State and organizational
core participants and other providers
um corporates or institutional
statements signed off at the highest
level
setting out the organization's Narrative
of events so far as it was involved or
so far as it observed the conduct of the
others now I pause at this point to
address Mata that was addressed this
morning
about slowing the process down or being
adversarial that is not what we are
submitting here
um we absolutely think the opposite
um is the case with position statements
we do not think that position statements
with public authorities in particular
particularly in a an inquiry of this
nature
needs to wait until there is significant
disclosure
a position statement is not asking for
participants to do with respect to your
job
it's asking them to State what they did
it's effectively putting if a narrative
burden an evidential burden perhaps in
more legal terms onto them rather than
you and your team so uh in terms of
slowing the process down absolutely the
opposite because it would put a onus on
the core participant to identify
everything about their own conduct and
their own narrative
rather than simply others having to
search within their domain for it
in terms of being adversarial
we respectfully ask how is asking a core
participant to assist the inquiry by
saying what did or did not happen how is
that adversarial again we say it's part
of a proper institutional approach
inquisitorial approach
the statements that we seek the position
statements we seek would include the
responsibilities the legal and
Regulatory framework within which the
organization Works what did and didn't
happen so far as relevant to the terms
of reference in the particular module
and what failures and what good practice
it can identify to assist the process it
should identify relevant material and
the issues on the terms of reference to
which it applies
and an inquiry as huge as this one
and this approach would be key in our
submission so cutting to the center of
the issues and it avoids the inquiry
having to identify their Haystacks never
mind the needles that might be lying
within them and this has been an
approach taken by inquiry chairs
recently
so we've set out in in writing from
paragraph 21 onwards
the general approach was extensively
looked at in the by the working group in
the law Reform Group Justice
which expressly the reporter which
expressly endorsed
um the approach of using position
statements and importantly for my
submission certainly is that three uh of
your fellow senior judges who very
considerable experience in this area
were Central to that Justice process and
that Justice report
uh Sir Robert Owen
who chaired dylanco inquiry Sir John
Goldring who was the coroner in
Hillsborough and Sir Peter Thornton who
was a previous
um Chief coroner given the number of
issues the number of potential material
providers putting this initial burden on
them to identify roles issues narrative
what may have gone wrong is in our
submission not only the right approach
but it's a common sense starting
approach and it should expedite the
inquiry's work it's an approach which
has been deployed it was deployed with a
great effect in the Manchester Arena
inquiry and to some effect in the
gramful tower inquiry
from the Gathering of evidence can I now
briefly turn to the disclosure of of the
material to core participants
uh paragraph 49 of the council's note to
um Council for the inquiries note
there is reference to quote focused and
proportionate disclosure to core
participants to allow them to
effectively participate in the hearings
and some discussion about that was had
earlier
I say
candidly I don't know what that means I
don't know what test is set out
um there at all
what is it who would apply it
practically we assume we hope
that material will come into the inquiry
undergo a potential relevance test now
no doubt a screening for material which
should properly be taken out personal
details such like and then disclosed on
an ongoing basis in tranches
um rhetorically how is the solicitor or
Council within the inquiry team
undertaking this task day-to-day or more
likely a small army of solicitors and
Council given the volume here how are
they how are the individuals there to do
this without a clearly set out test
and given that there will be electronic
disclosure there's no greater burden in
adopting the approach taken in other
inquiries and inquests and that of
disclosing all potential potentially
relevant material subjects and narrower
exceptions and we've set out I won't
repeat them but we set out five reasons
why this is the appropriate approach
from paragraphs 29 of our written
submissions but what they amount to in
summary is proper transparency
uh consistency of approach across the
material
and facilitating the effective
participation of core participants
if Court participants are only given a
um
part of the evidence how is it that they
can properly engage within the inquiry
now we do obviously understand that
there will be a substantial amount of
material generated
uh we do understand that the inquiry
must apply a proper relevance test here
however the approach currently indicated
appears to reduce the disclosure process
to an arbitrary one without any
consistency or proper standard or test
experts we know that the indication that
you will consider suggestions as to
experts on the questions they're asked
to address will be made available prior
to finalization of reports but again
um rolling back to dialogue it will be
helpful if we could have a more of a
two-way street as the inquiry progresses
on on this point
um effective participation again means
called participants all of us
collaborating with the inquiry and
searching for evidence and answers it
appears to us and we perceive that it's
the approach of the inquiry that there
will be the need for a significant areas
of of expert evidence
uh and we agree agree with that
we also agree with submissions made by
other core participants that in an
inquiry like this it will be impossible
not just difficult but impossible to
find experts who've not already
expressed views I think those are the
submissions of Mr Beer in particular for
the NHS England
and there is the need for a balancing of
groups of experts which I think he's
putting forward and with which we most
certainly agree and will endeavor to
assist in the identification of relevant
experts
with a listening exercise of course this
is the area of most current concern to
family members as you know in earlier
submissions and those for today we've
identified that there are three key
areas of evidence which the bereaved
Cannon should provide to the inquiry
commemorative evidence regarding their
lost loved ones
evidence of circumstance of death and
evidence regarding the effect of loss on
the breed themselves there are of course
other categories to which particular
family family members can contribute but
these seem to be the main three strands
and we made written submissions in April
and June regarding those
we haven't had a substantive response or
again any real discussion or dialogue
about those submissions
um the listening projects or now the
listening exercise appears to be cast as
a parallel process
and the bereaved learned from the
guardian about a tender process how how
accurate that was I'll leave others to
say
but nevertheless the families were
concerned to learn from the media about
a tender process which apparently was
directed at companies from a government
approved list
which may have played a role some of
them may have played a role in
government messaging regarding the
pandemic itself
whether or not that's an entirely
accurate picture that's put across it
has caused real concern in in the family
and with the families
if it is that the inquiry is Seeking a
strategy a plan as to how to take the
evidence of the breed and of course
others
then within its own team it has quite a
a cohort of very experienced lawyers who
have engaged in these processes before
so do we
and we've absolutely want to collaborate
with your team in coming up with a
process that actually works and has the
confidence and buy-in of the bereaved
and allows the inquiry to take this very
important evidence in the best way
possible
but if the learning exercise is to be a
process outside of the inquiry
to which the bereaved and anybody else
affected provides information about
their experiences or indeed anything
that they wish to contribute
and that is a matter of some concern
that the assertion is an early stage of
this before the process is even properly
formed
so there'll be no resourcing for the
breed to receive help assistance or
advice from their representatives is
equally troubling given the experience
from a wide range of inquiries and
inquests about the necessity for it
so far as I'm aware
there's been no contact with inquest for
charity who for 40 years has been the
central charity involved in dealing with
the bereaved and their needs within
um such processes and may I just in
passing declare an interest because I'm
actually a trustee of invest
but it would be
essential in my submission to involve
organizations such as inquest with their
wealth of
um expertise in this area to play a role
in the formulation of any
um such process
we have asked but we've not been
informed as to who would take the
information from family members or
others and what their training or
expertise would be
the information supplied we're told will
be analyzed and a report will be
provided then considered by the inquiry
again with asper not being told who it
is that would analyze such material or
how or what training or expertise they
would have
or indeed how the inquiry would consider
the report or to what end
or indeed how the inquiry would quality
control the taking or the analysis of
such material
the only guidance that we've had is that
we might like to look at the process of
the truth project
in EXA the independent inquiry into
child sexual abuse
now we note that that inquiry was
primarily about institutional child
abuse and not huge loss of life so quite
different
anecdotally we note that many who were
involved
um certainly professionally were
critical of that process
and it's not clear to us looking in at
that process how the the products of it
was considered or whether it influenced
the inquiry itself
we're not aware of any post-truth
project analysis of how or whether it
worked
that we're not aware of any other case
where this approach has been taken
there's reference in the
um solicitor to the inquiry note of the
13th of September
that a research analyst company is
proposed to be instructed to do this
work we're not aware of this as a
discipline or indeed of
expertise or experience which would
allow
an outsourced company to deal with it
our submissions on the other hand
referred to other inquests and other
inquiries in some fatalities we're not
suggesting they're the same
and the way in which the evidence of the
breed has been considered in the past
and to the current guidance of the T
coroner on-pem portraits
we also made it quite clear and
repeatedly so that we did understand
that every process is different
that we understood that this inquiry
will not look at the circumstances of
each death individually how could it
and we made clear that we took notice
that the extent of loss of life to the
pandemic means that a proportionate
approach has to be taken here and we set
out preliminary proposals as to how that
might be done with all that in in mind
those submissions are being
characterized as heartfelt
and that they call for quote extensive
hearing of pen portraits
but the reality is that the submissions
are based on what has worked in the past
but they're crafted to provide starting
proposals proportionate proposals which
would properly engage and value the
bereaved
um but without having any
disproportionate effect on progress or
on cost for the inquiry
now of course if those submissions are
to be given further consideration we
would absolutely wish to do so and would
engage fully
um with that and we're happy to
discuss as far as anybody wishes us to
what we mean by the proportionate
approach and because we are committed to
the approach that you've taken into
driving the inquiry forward
Mr Keith referred to Little B in the
terms of reference to listen to and
consider carefully the experiences of
bereaved families and others who have
suffered hardship or loss as a result of
the pandemic
the listening exercise proposal as cast
up to now with in our respectful
submission does not do this it
outsources examination of the
experiences and the evidence of the
bereaved and of that loss and it places
them in a parallel adult process outside
of the statutory inquiry framework and
it does with respect
uh marginalized the breed and their
voices
uh I'm not going to repeat the points
we've made earlier about
um how how it should be done
but firstly the inquiry should
facilitate the Gathering of
commemorative evidence and our
submission from those who wish to do so
it should explore with us their
representatives how this can be done in
a proportionate and fair way and that
the inquiry process should include a
proportionate amount of this evidence
within it not an extensive and
disproportionate section which diverts
the inquiry
a clear recognition that the inquiry
wants to hear and recognize that first
hand the loss the experience and the
experience of the bereaved hearing
commemorative evidence
that first hand has no substitute it
cannot be provided through a parallel
process it can and should be done in a
dignified yet proportionate passion
moving on
in respect of
um
the investigation of individual debts
we've been assisted this morning by some
further clarification which we certainly
hadn't picked up before
but we were going to ask you for a clear
signal that a proportionate amount of
witness evidence of those who can give
out direct evidence of circumstances of
death that would be called for key
issues such as the 111 service and DNR
we're reassured by what has been said
this morning that that is in fact your
intention and that you will be hearing
first-hand witness evidence of what
actually happened to assist you in
determining the terms of reference on
those points
and thirdly and briefly we think that a
similar approach a proportionate amount
of evidence should be taken to give the
experiences of the loss on the bereaved
themselves
finally moving on briefly to Future
hearings
um I've already emphasized the family's
frustrations at the time to get to this
point
and the imperative that this
wide-ranging inquiry is kept within a
proper time scale Point we've repeatedly
made and which we perceive is entirely
in tune with your own approach
it should aim to take the shortest
possible time be as long as is necessary
we respectfully agree that the inquiry
has set a realistic and proper start
date for the hearings of module one
spring next year
however we do flag at this stage our
surprise that it's thought that the
whole of preparedness across the United
Kingdom and within the devolved Nations
and jurisdictions can be dealt with
properly Within
four weeks again the first we heard of
that was in cti's note but we're not
aware of how that estimate has been
reached all we ask at this stage is that
the inquiry revisits it and revisits it
in time as more is known about the
progress of module one and finally this
I reiterate the bereaved families
recognize the work that has been
undertaken to date
they campaigned hard for a full
independent statutory inquiry they're
fully invested in its success and what
they really seek as an indication that
they will actually be based front and
Central to the pro process as you've
promised including through affected
participation in the process and that
you'll take due account of the
submissions we've made this morning
thank you Mr Weatherby I'm very grateful
to the bereaved family organizations for
their help in organizing the
consultation on the terms of reference
and for introducing me to so many
members of bereaved families it was
extraordinarily helpful and as we've
heard today fed into my recommendations
on the terms of reference
I welcome also your offer of a
collaborative approach and I hope that
always remains the case because we
simply can't get through this inquiry
given the complexities uh without that
kind of collaboration
I will obviously reflect uh on all the
submissions that you've made this
morning but I just want to say a couple
of things to put the record straight
because I know how distressed people are
already traumatized by grief can be if
they see something perhaps misunderstood
in reports there is absolutely no
question that the bereave will be
marginalized and I really don't ever
want to hear that expression again
because as I hope those families to whom
I spoke understand and I hope your
members will understand I am determined
that those who have suffered will be at
the heart of this inquiry so any plans
that we are developing as far as the
listening exercise and commemoration are
concerned will ensure that they are not
marginalized as you know the intention
of the listening exercise is far from
marginalizing the bereaved is to extend
the number of people who suffered and
the number of bereaved to have suffered
to many many thousands more than we
could do in the ordinary classic way of
a formal hearing but the reason you
haven't had any answers to your
questions is that the plans are in an
early stage of development you know Mr
Weatherby how hard everyone's been
working to try and get this inquiry
underway and as soon as we have uh
sensible suggestions we will of course
make sure that your lay clients are
properly consulted and of course all the
others the other core participants and
the and people who've suffered in other
ways so I hope that you and those whom
you represent are reassured by those
comments but the bereaved will remain at
the heart part of this inquiry as all
the others have suffered will do so too
so thank you for your submissions
right
is next uh slavery
[Music]
Mr levy my lady thank you
um just for the record the the
neighbor's Library oh I'm so sorry thank
you now please make that mistake again
please if anyone correct me it hesitate
to uh thank you for giving us the
opportunity to address you here in
person and it is great to see so many
people here in person
um I represent the Northern Ireland
covid-19 brief families for justice and
I'm
real men lovely I'm here with Mr Conan
Fagan who is another Barrister in Mr
mcguyen and the end of my guardian Conor
McGarry they're here as well we
represent our families in Northern
Ireland
and
um they will be heartened to hear what
you just said melody in terms of them
being at the heart of participation in
this inquiry
and they
we are here to represent them
in London Northern Ireland is a place
geographically removed from here and
we're here to represent them as this
inquiry proceeds
and we're here to we have
prepared a joint submission to the
inquiry
and I hope that you will see that as a
way that we want to collaborate
responsibly with the other
families from the other jurisdictions
and I endorse entirely
what Mr Weatherby was saying I'm not
going to repeat that in that manner
and
and as I say we're heartened to hear
some of what Mr Keith said today and
what you're saying as well and that the
door will be open and that just as we're
collaborating together that we want to
collaborate as well with the inquiry
going forward
the the families I represent were very
impressed
with the listening exercise which did
happen in Belfast
and we're struck with
your Humanity my lady
under the Czar wish that that Humanity
continues throughout this process
and it sounds from what has been said
today that it will
because although as Mr Keith pointed out
we're dealing here with high level
decision making or a group of lawyers
examining not scrutinizing it
this is of course about human beings and
humanity and that won't be lost
um on unusuality
and
when one is looking at this
from an Northern Irish perspective there
are decisions that were made out of the
uk-wide level that impact on Northern
Ireland and we will collaborate with the
other
nations on those issues but there are
also decisions that were made in
Northern Ireland
and Northern Ireland is a unique place
not just geographically as I've
explained and as the set out in our
submissions as well there are some
features that are unique to Northern
Ireland
they and so what we want to impress upon
you the importance of dealing with these
issues in module one as well and they
seem to have been looked at in a more
separate and different way module two
and simply I suppose we want to impress
upon the inquiry
the importance of this for our families
there is no Northern Ireland inquiry and
so this is their opportunity to shape
the outcome of this inquiry in a
collaborative way
some of the unique features of Northern
Ireland
um are
um this may come as a surprise to many
people we don't actually have an NHS we
have a Universal Health Care system and
which is branded in different ways
we have an Amalgamated Health and Social
care system again different from the
England and Wales model
um we have a unique constitutional
arrangement in terms of decision making
at a devolved level
there is mandatory Coalition and hurdles
that have to be surmounted before any
kind of decision is made for instance if
they're significant or controversial
then they have to be referred to the
executive and so that is a unique
feature
and of course and I'm back to geography
uh North and South
the island as one epidemiological unit
is something that is of course unique
and there was a I understand the
memorandum of understanding uh between
the jurisdictions North and South and
the impact of that the effectiveness of
it is something that we would invite the
inquiry to look at
um
I'm not going to say an awful lot more
my lady
um Mr Weatherby has dealt with the
issues and they say that's our
collaborative effort and on the issue of
disclosure
and we are Keen to hit the ground
running and if there is we're looking at
hearing in May if we want to look at
materials as quickly as possible and
make sure that we're prepared for that
and that we can deal with this as
expeditiously as possible and that there
won't be delays in the in the scheduling
and so it's just lastly then our
family's concern is that we have a real
rule in this inquiry that the unique
Northern Irish situation is dealt with
and that they're not somehow a dealt
with as a footnote to the inquiry and
that's the phrase that they have used so
we hope and it's RM their legal team to
make sure that that doesn't happen
thank you very much for studying thank
you for your comments about my trip to
Belfast
um I think as you'll recall I mean I've
failed to believe anybody could be not
moved by what we heard
um from the families on that occasion
and indeed throughout the UK so thank
you very much for your comments and for
your offer of collaborative working and
I really do appreciate it from all of
you and as far as many of the unique
aspects of Northern Ireland are
concerned if I didn't know about some of
them before I certainly do know and I
can promise the people of Northern
Ireland that for as long as I am the
only inquiry into Northern Ireland we
will ensure that all the aspects that
your lay clients wish to be considered
indeed the public in Northern Ireland
wish to be considered if they are of
course what we in the indetermined
irrelevant then they will be so thank
you very much for your comments thank
you
right
um Miss Mitchell
I'm sorry about this having to come to
the lectum
[Music]
smell easy
over the last two years the Scottish
covid-19 believed families for justice
group has campaigned for a robust
independent and transparent public
inquiry into the handling of the
pandemic
the Scottish families welcomed the
approach of malady and the inquiry in
assuring them that their voices will be
heard at the UK inquiry and will be
heartened this morning to hear the
comments that they will be at the heart
of this inquiry
today is the start of the process and
The Grieving families in Scotland
hope that this public inquiry will be
both an effective and credible mechanism
to ensure what happens to them will not
happen again
we hope to assist the inquiry to ensure
this happens
senior Council to the inquiry has set
out very broadly the Masters to be
explored in module 1.
having spoken to him and the solicitor
to the inquiry we appreciate that given
the amount of information that's been
processed by the inquiry at present no
greater specification is possible
given this situation combined with the
lack of disclosure to as at present it's
difficult to know whether all the issues
we wish covered will in fact be in there
in order to assist the inquiry we look
forward to disclosure commencing and for
appropriate and possible a list of
issues and or questions at the earliest
opportunity in order that we can assist
by flagging up anything that we see as
emissions or in or suggest any
additional issues to be
we appreciate senior counsel to the
inquiries comments this morning that he
will approach such suggestions from the
court participants with an open Indeed
eager frame of mind
we're keen to start working in
disclosure and we hope that before the
further preliminary hearing in early
2023 will be in a better position to
help the inquiry in this regard
I now turn to address four specific
issues
one the listening exercise
as no doubt appreciated by the inquiry
the ability for individuals to explain
how covet affected them and their loved
ones personally is something which is
hugely important to the people that we
represent in Scotland
my lady we welcome the comments in your
opening remarks with regard to the
listening exercise for those that we
represent it is a crucial part of the
inquiry process and again indeed they
will be heartened to find out my lady's
comments on that this morning
once the information collected in the
exercise is analyzed and presented in a
report
will bring considerable value to this
inquiry
we have had constructive meetings with
the inquiry legal team in respect to the
listening exercise we do understand that
at present there are still a number of
matters to be considered and have made
some representations already on our
views we look forward to continued
discussion in that regard
we are Keen to ensure that there is
there are as many ways as possible to
facilitate listening by speaking to
someone providing a written response
using technology or really by whatever
means the inquiry can think of that
would be appropriate and also we're keen
to ensure that the people carrying out
the process are suitable for that role
two watching proceedings
it is important to those that we
represent to have the opportunity to
watch the proceedings
and we note that thanks to the benefits
of Technology proceedings will be placed
online with a short time delay
this doesn't however assist those who
don't have computers don't have access
to Wi-Fi are not tech savvy or simply
don't have the ability to watch online
we would ask that the inquiry gives
consideration to finding places if you
like listening rooms which could be made
available in Scotland so that that with
the use of Technology the work of the
inquiry and the hearings could be viewed
by people wishing to attend those places
we would ask that consideration be given
to this to be put in place for the next
hearing
number three the Scottish inquiry
the inquiry has already stated its aim
to work alongside the Scottish inquiry
to assure that there is as little
duplication of work as possible
we're glad this morning to hear the
memorandum of understanding is being
thrown up and we hope that that will
minimize any problems that will arise
there will however no doubt the issues
on which there are queries as to whether
or not the matter is properly an issue
for the UK inquiry or a Scottish inquiry
we would ask that we can assist the
inquiry in providing our views if and
when those matters arise
on a practical note we would also ask
that the inquiries work together in so
far as as possible not to sit at the
same time as those we represent have a
direct interest in both inquiries
four memorialization
we agree and support the idea of a
memorial as mentioned by senior Council
to the inquiry
under consideration as we understand it
at present is a commemorative Memorial
in the future Hearing Center
we understand that The Healing Center
will be in London at least for the first
module
particularly in the present Financial
climate traveling to London to view a
memorial would simply be neither
practical nor viable for many people in
Scotland we welcome the comments this
morning by senior Council that
consideration is being given to the
memorial being mobile and we would ask
that any Memorial which is decided upon
is capable of being moved so that when
the inquiry visits Scotland and
elsewhere people have an opportunity to
see it my lady these are the submissions
on behalf of the Scottish covid-19 brief
families for justice group thank you
very much indeed spiritual and
um your constructive support is is
absolutely very welcome and very much
appreciated so thank you very much and
the idea of listening rooms is is an
excellent suggestion and we'll certainly
look into whether it's going to be
possible
um I know a number of people who fall
into the category that you've described
who would welcome that kind of
opportunity for a listing room so thank
you for that idea and I I can undertake
that we'll give you as much notice as
possible whenever we can and I'm sorry
that people didn't have them that much
notice of today's hearing and the list
of issues
um but we will give you as much notice
as we can as Mr Keith has indicated so
thank you very much indeed I'm obliged
that's helpful Mindy
right
um the seven that's it
yes accumulating
I represent the covid-19 brief families
for justice Camry a group dedicated
solely to campaigning for a bust
independent and transparent scrutiny
into the preparation for and response to
the pandemic in Wales
the group has worked tirelessly to give
a voice to those bereaved by covid-19 in
Wales and they are heartened to hear
today that the Welsh voices will be at
the heart of this inquiry
the covid-19 brief families for justice
comree wish to thank the chair for
designating them as a core participant
in the module one hearings of this
public inquiry and for the chair's
recognition that they are best placed to
assist this public inquiry to achieve
its aims by representing the collective
interests of a broad spectrum of those
bereaved by covid-19 in Wales in
relation to module one
the covid-19 brief family suggests this
country also welcome the chair's very
clear commitment to looking at the
actions of the devolved administrations
however as the chair will be aware there
are still concerns in Wales and indeed
in all of the other devolved
administrations that the preliminary
scope of module one does not set out in
any detail the issues specific to Wales
that ought to be investigated by this
public inquiry
it is vitally important that the people
of Wales can have full confidence that
this public inquiry will scrutinize
decision-making Wales in respect of the
pandemic
the group does welcome the chair's
indication that this public inquiry will
come and hear evidence in Wales for
certain modules
Wales is a separate country
and although Wales receives funding from
the United Kingdom government
responsibility for Health and Social
care is devolved to the Welsh government
Wales has its own Health Care system
and NHS Wales is comprised of local
Health boards and NHS trusts
there is a public health Wales and
relevant offices and agencies such as
the office of the chief medical officer
and Care inspectorate are specific to
Wales
key decisions made in Wales in relation
to the covid-19 pandemic were largely
separate to and quite often distinct
from those taken by the UK government
however Wales does have strong
connections with the UK government and
the other devolved governments and so it
will be necessary in module one to
unravel the links between these
governments and the extent to which they
influenced the Welsh government whether
for good or for bad
in relation to preparedness whilst the
UK influenza pandemic prepared and
strategy 2011 concerned a uk-wide
strategic approach to planning for and
responding to the demands of an
influenza pandemic the cabinet office
guidance of November 2017 on pandemic
flu planning made absolutely clear that
devolved administrations are responsible
for the major areas of pandemic
influenza planning and response in their
respective countries
it also made clear that it was the Wales
resilience Forum chaired by the first
Minister for Wales that provides the
mechanism for a national multi-agency
overview of pandemic preparedness in
Wales
there can therefore be no doubt that
responsibility for pandemic planning in
Wales would largely if not entirely in
the hands of the Welsh government
in relation to module 1 the covid-19
brief family for justice Camry just wish
to highlight a few particular areas of
concern that they have and that this
public inquiry must scrutinize in
relation to Wales in module one
these include whether the level of
funding provided to Wales by the UK
government had an impact on the planning
and preparedness in Wales for the
pandemic and the political relations
between Wales and the UK government
coordination between the UK government
and all the devolved governments and the
variation in standards in the approach
to preparedness for a pandemic
the preparedness in NHS Wales in the
Welsh Hospital estate and in Welsh care
homes in respect of infection control
measures including segregation
resourcing PPE stockpiling and
distribution
and whether there was adequate or indeed
any planning in relation to post theft
procedures to protect dignity and to
support the Welsh bereaved in the event
of a pandemic
so the covid-19 brief families for
justice cambrie will will be making
further submission to the public inquiry
on all the procedural matters raised by
Council of the inquiry today and after
disclosure has been received however the
country group is also of the view that
position statements are going to be
essential in understanding in an
efficient way what happened in Wales in
relation to preparedness
the kobit 19 brief families for justice
country are committed to working with
the inquiry team to assist in developing
the listening exercise in Wales and
stand ready to work collaboratively with
the chair in developing the scope of
module one in relation to Wales thank
you thank you very much indeed
um I do understand
um the concerns expressed about the
approach to devolved Nations and whether
the provisional scope has um set to set
it out appropriately so I will very much
look into that and I'm very grateful for
your helpful submissions thank you
uh Mr Birmingham
thank you
good afternoon mum I represent the
association of directors of Public
Health the adph
o my client is grateful for the
inquiry's recognition that the role of
the the role directors of Public Health
have taken in preparing for and
responding to the pandemic
our thoughts are of course with those
who have lost their lives in the
bereaved
adph is committed to this inquiry and to
helping it
deliver recommendations to ensure that
pandemic response will be better in
future
adph has far brief written submissions
and there are a few matters arising from
these and from the other submissions
that I would like to to address now
first is the question of how we
investigate pandemic preparedness
we are unclear if the inquiry intends to
take the high-level approach described
by Council to the inquiry and look at
the paper state of preparedness as at
say January 2020
or whether in investigating preparedness
the inquiry intends to look at what was
revealed about preparedness by the early
stages by events in the early stages of
the pandemic when gaps in the the
planning became apparent the example
given in our submissions is of
government departments who did not have
up-to-date contact details for directors
of Public Health that seems to us to be
a gap in the planning but it is only
when you descend into the early events
of the inquiry that that Gap becomes
apparent
that
clearly um our submissions are that the
inquiry should look into those early
weeks of the pandemic but to be clear we
are not suggesting that in module one in
preparedness we go deep into the
pandemic and into late events looking at
the question of preparedness what we're
interested in is systemic failures that
are revealed by the early the Early
events
next up is the local government
perspective as the inquiry will be aware
that has been a trend towards the
unification of Health and Social care
over recent years in recent legislation
as a result local authorities were at
the Forefront of pandemic response and
in pandemic preparation
their plans their preparation are
important for understanding how well
prepared our society was
in light of that it's slightly
surprising to see that we only have two
organizations here dealing with local
governments in the form of my client and
the LGA
it's my client's submission the more
detail on the local government position
is needed and in that respect to
organizations that would would be able
to assist the inquiry significantly are
the association of directors of adult
social services and the association of
directors of children's services
local authorities are at the Forefront
of Service delivery in respect of both
children and vulnerable adults and those
organizations will be able to assist on
how those aspects of pandemic response
were were planned for
in addition
my client suggests that we could look at
undertaking some preparedness case
studies around individual local
authorities or the inquiry could make
rule 9 requests of individual local
authorities on the question of
preparedness
the the local authorities that we choose
would need to be selected to be
contrasting local authorities
contrasting parts of the country contact
contrasting areas of affluence and so
forth
the next issue to comment upon is the
question of position statements
the association is against the question
against finding of witness statements
and was supported and supports what was
said by by Mr Keith earlier
physician statements would effectively
have us pleading in the inquiry and a
position statement filed before we've
had an opportunity to really descend
into the documents we've been no more
than a statement of an organization's
early impression of its pandemic
response rather than a detailed and
thought out narrative as such we don't
think that position statements will help
that said
adph recognizes that it's important that
this inquiry understands the role of
directors of Public Health particularly
as it differs across the the four
countries and so it suggests filing
witness evidence to an early stage to
explain that to the inquiry and to
provide the inquiry with its documents
and then after that for the inquiry to
move to the question of rule nine
requests of the of the association
turning to disclosure adph has great
Sympathy For What the survivors say
about wanting to see all of the
paperwork that encourages transparency
it creates an impression of openness and
so we don't oppose that submission in
principle however
in the interests of balance we do have
to comment that this inquiry is going to
acquire a vast amounts of paperwork it
will be millions of pages
we're talking about amounts of paperwork
so vast that electronic document
Management Systems Search terms use of
AI to index and audit it will be
required to control it and as such the
inquiry has to strike a balance and
therefore the position that we take is
one of neutrality on that but we need to
be assured that the the inquiry is
giving the relevant stuff and therefore
there is a place perhaps for identifying
the material that has been has been left
out on the subject of disclosure of
documents generally
um it's clear that central government
departments have been asked to preserve
documents thanks to Keith mentioned uh
January 2021 in respect of that the
question is whether local authorities
should also be asked to preserve
documents because they will be sitting
on vast amounts of material which would
also be of relevance to to the inquiry
the final point for adph is one of
perception it's it's about openness it's
vital that this inquiry carries the
Survivor Community carries
um full public confidence and that's
about a perception of openness and in
this information age the more open the
inquiry appears to be the better it will
be received by the public
on that basis when the core
participation determinations were made
it was a little surprising to learn that
we had become a core participant but
that we couldn't communicate that fact
and that fact was not going to go up on
the inquiry website until after today
I know that nothing Sinister is intended
by that I know that that's just about
information management but it is one of
those things that just created a slight
perception that maybe the inquiry wasn't
being as open as it could be as quickly
as it could be and dealing with any
misperceptions around openness adph
submits is extremely important
if unless there's anything else I can
help you with Mom that's that's awesome
thank you very much indeed you make some
interesting points and one of the first
things I said to the inquiry team was
that I believe in openness and so I mean
the last point
it hadn't occurred to me until you made
it so thank you very much and the other
points to
um important points and we'll reflect
upon them thank you thank you
foreign
and my lady as you know I act for the
trades Union Congress the TUC along with
Mr Jacobs and instructed by Thompson's
solicitors and may we start by saying
how grateful we are to be a core
participant in this vitally important
module and as the TUC has made clear in
its engagement prior to the official
commencement of this inquiry and since
your opening statement in July we seek
to bring forward the experience and
expertise of the TUC members and the TUC
member unions for the benefit of this
important inquiry and we intend to do
that to the extent we can through the
life of the inquiry and of course also
we wish to protect the interests of our
members and member unions unconscious
you have detail in the written materials
before you about the TUC but I just want
to start by saying something brief for
those who are watching us in the room
and online about that
TUC brings together 5.5 million working
people who make up its 48 member unions
from all parts of the UK from all four
countries each of those 48 member unions
is listed as an Annex to the submissions
that we've given you and as that list
makes clear my lady they span a very
wide range of Industries profoundly
affected by the covid-19 pandemic
including many Frontline roles
Mr Keith King's Council canceled to the
inquiry referenced in his opening
remarks today the vast swathes of human
and social activity which were curtailed
halted or impacted by the covid-19
pandemic and the official response to it
and if you look at the list that he gave
and you look at the 48 member unions you
see a very substantial overlap because
the remit is breathtakingly broad it
includes by way of example only midwives
workers in Food Industries head teachers
teachers teachers lecturers those
working in adult education probation
prison and family court staff workers in
Social care manufacturing nurseries coal
mining the voluntary sector Aviation and
a great many more it also includes
groups such as freelance artists
journalists bus drivers call center
workers civil servants a huge range and
to use Mr it's phrase It's vast swathes
of human and social activity reflected
in the tuc's work
critically my lady thousands of people
of working age died in the pandemic many
of whom were key workers in high risk
workplaces in sectors such as Health
social care transport food processing
and textiles and a great many of whom
were TUC members
workers from ethnic minorities were
particularly hard hit as you'll hear
through this inquiry with on the
statistics we have available BME men 57
more likely to be working in jobs with a
high mortality rate BMA BME women 48
more likely to be working in jobs with a
higher mortality rate and indeed that
Echoes Mr weatherby's submissions a
little earlier on behalf of the bereaved
families and his group
and many thousands of TUC members died
as a result of the covid-19 pandemic
tens of thousands continue to suffer the
effects of long covert and pandemic
related workplace injury
and many more are bereaved many have
suffered hardship or loss in a myriad of
ways
and I did want to quote what the TUC
General Secretary Francis O'Grady said
in April of this year in a joint
statement released with the covert
bereaved families for justice on workers
Memorial Day and that of course was
before the inquiry's terms of reference
were finalized and she said we'll
forever be in the debt of the workers
who kept the country going during the
pandemic nurses Heroes bus drivers
Factory workers and so many more
far too many were exposed to the virus
at work and lost their lives as a
consequence
now the government owes it to them and
to their families to make sure the
public inquiry investigates what should
have been done to keep everyone safe at
work
now since that time of course the terms
of reference have been finalized and the
bat on has been passed from the
government to you and your team and my
lady and echoing those words
from the general secretary in April we
say now the inquiries are to them and
their families to ensure that the
inquiry investigates what should have
been done to keep everyone safe at work
and what should be done in future and
we're very grateful for the clear and
robust recognition in your opening
statement of July
and again in your words today of the
vital importance of learning as swiftly
as possible if anything could or should
have been done to prevent or reduce that
suffering and those values
and we were struck my lady by the fact
that at the outset of today's hearing
you indicated that there's one word that
sums up the pandemic for so many and
that word is loss
for the TUC TUC members and member
unions we wholeheartedly agree
for many of our members we would use two
words
avoidable laws losses which may have
been avoided had the UK been prepared
and ready in early 2020 and losses which
may be avoidable in future if lessons
are learned and learned swiftly and the
right lessons are learned
and that's why we've made clear in our
written submissions that we agree
entirely that module one is a vital and
Urgent topic which cannot wait
you raise a pressing question in the
scope for module one
was the UK prepared for a pandemic or
indeed for another form of civil
emergency
this is a vitally important issue it
must be considered as soon as possible
and that's precisely why we agree with
your commitment
the timeliness and we agree with them
endorse in your opening remarks today
the reference to the importance of
timeliness the Striking a balance
between timeliness and the extent to
which you were able to explore each and
every single issue within the very broad
scope of the terms of reference but
equally my lady we agree entirely with
the point you made in your written
opening statement in July 2022 at page 8
where you said given the breadth of my
investigations this will not be
completed as quickly as some might like
I make no apology for that I'm
determined to ensure that the inquiry
has access to the evidence it needs and
has the time to analyze that evidence
properly before Witnesses appear in
front of me and in the submissions we
make today we bear very much in mind
those driving factors that you
identified today and you identified in
July 2022 and it's precisely because of
your clear commitment which we welcome
to timeliness to avoiding unnecessary
delay but also to ensuring that you have
the right evidence before you before
embarking on public hearings that we
respectfully request on three topics
that you adopt the approach proposed by
the TUC and the bereaved families and
respectfully we request that you do take
a slightly different approach to that
proposed by your Council this morning
and those three topics are disclosure of
rule 9 requests
disclosure of letters of instruction to
experts
and disclosure more generally
and the tester approach to apply I'll
take those in turn
so starting firstly my lady with rule 9
requests
we agree with Mr Weatherby King's
Council that rule 9 requests should be
disclosed to core participants
now in the submissions made by Mr Keith
King's Council this morning he said
you are neither required by the rules
nor is it established by past practice
he also used the phrase that it would
serve no purpose and he made reference
to practical difficulties given the
iterative process and may I summarize
our submissions under two headings one
principle and one practicality
so in relation to principle my lady
the TUC welcomed in our April 2022
consultation response the principles you
set out in your open letter announcing
that consultation process there was a
clear and very welcome commitment to
transparency and to inclusiveness we
recognize of course that Mr Keith is
correct that rule 9 requests are not
mandated to be automatically disclosed
by the rules but in exercising your
discretion we say that transparency
which you've been committed to from the
ad set is a key factor to bear in mind
the rules are essentially neutral
there's no mandatory requirement to
disclose there's also no barrier to
disclose and as a matter of principle we
say you should disclose other inquiries
have taken that step and chairs when
exercising their discretion have
disclosed rule 9 requests by way of
example familiar to many of your team
rule 9 requests were disclosed in a
number of the independent inquiry and
Charles saxabies modules
so we ask you to exercise your
discretion to disclose as a matter of
principle and indeed we say that that
would be in keeping with another phrase
used by Mr Keith this morning when he
referred to having an open Indeed eager
frame of mind so for transparency
reasons in principle we ask that they be
disclosed
secondly practicality
our submission is that it would be
efficient and time saving to disclose
the rule 9 requests and to do so early
we noted Mr Keith's words this morning
referring to the rule 9 requests already
made being described as lengthy complex
and wide-ranging we assume as their
lengthy complex and wide-ranging it's
likely to take some time for the
resulting witness statements to come
back to you and to your team
the advantage of CPS having early sight
of those rule 9 requests is we can feed
in we can identify if there are gaps we
can suggest additional queries or
clarifications on the ambitious
timetable you've set out we have under
seven months to the start of may we can
see the preparation of these witness
statements may take some months we do
not want to be in a position where we
hit Spring 2023 and we start to receive
statements which make clear that there
was a blind spot or a gap we want to
avoid that and the reference to the
iterative process that was made earlier
seems to us not to be a point against us
it's a point in favor of disclosure it's
precisely why the rule 9 requests can be
disclosed and we can go back and we make
that submission without doubting in any
way the diligence and expertise of your
solicitor team and your Council team but
necessarily there will be information
unavailable to them which is available
to core participants given their
backgrounds and their expertise the TUC
for example the British Medical
Association the local government
Association may have information unknown
to your legal team if I can adopt a
phrase from Donald Rumsfeld there will
be unknown unknowns they simply won't
know what gaps there are in their
knowledge and what we want to avoid is a
situation where we get close to the May
hearing we receive statements we can see
there are gaps in them and we then have
a last-minute scramble which seems to us
to cut against your commitment to
timeliness and to trying to ensure that
the timetable is adhered to
a good example of a collaborative
approach with the disclosure of rule 9
requests came in Mr Keith's welcome
words this morning referring to the
health and safety executive that's not
about disclosure of the rule 9 request
itself but it is an example of where the
TUC has raised a concern and we're very
grateful for the indication this morning
that our suggestion that a rule 9
request be made to the health and safety
executive is now under consideration
you'll have seen our submissions on that
point of paragraph 25 in particular and
taken shortly
this is an issue of vital importance to
the TUC
it's intimately linked to subtopic 2 in
your provisional scope document risk
management
the TUC for over a decade since 2010 has
been raising grave concerns that
systematic underfunding of vital
services including safety regulations
places the UK at risk and as you've seen
the tuc's view is that the UK's pandemic
preparedness was Gravely undermined by a
number of historical changes to risk
management structures and bodies and in
addition in addition by substantial cuts
to their budgets
you've seen our submission the funding
cuts to the HSE and local Authority
enforcement since 2010 seriously
hindered the regulator's ability to
effectively prevent workplace hazards to
tour employers from breaching
regulations and the law and put simply
the TUC has set out on our submissions
say that the effects of cuts to funding
resulted in fewer inspectors fewer
inspections much less enforcement action
prior to the pandemic Gravely therefore
weakened the resilience and preparedness
of risk management structures that's an
example where we were able to give a
reference to the HSE which didn't appear
in your early list and it's now under
consideration but a similar principle
would apply with disclosure of rule 9
requests where there simply may be
unknown gaps at which we and other core
participants may be able to fill
the second topic is disclosure of
letters of instruction to experts we
were grateful to hear and we welcome the
fact that today cancel to the inquiry
confirmed that those instructions will
indeed be provided to core participants
before the reports are finalized so we
welcome that we simply raise a timing
point the earlier those letters of
instruction can be provided to core
participants the earlier core
participants can identify any gaps or
any additional issues and return to you
again seeking to avoid a last-minute
scramble assuming that the reports will
take some time to prepare
and in some other inquiries we have seen
a situation where you get the report and
the letter of instruction disclosed at
the same time often three or four weeks
before the hearing and that doesn't
assist anyone seems to us if they're
going to be disclosed the earlier they
can be disclosed the better particularly
in circumstances where the TUC the
bereaved families and many other groups
are collectives who have large numbers
of people who they represent their
representative voices so the more time
we can have the better and we entirely
hear and understand the point Mr Keith
Made at the end of his submissions
earlier in relation to notice where he
said we'll give you as much as possible
but but time is against us and there's a
huge amount to be done but the letters
of instruction to experts is a good
example of where earlier disclosure will
avoid problems for everyone it's
accepted in principle they're going to
be disclosed the sooner we can see them
the better
the third point is about disclosure more
generally now we dealt with this in our
written submissions at paragraph 29 to
30 and the TUC is also in agreement with
the written submissions made by the
covid-19 bereaved families for justice
and the Northern Ireland covid-19
bereaved families for justice and indeed
with with Mr weatherby's oral
submissions today
the concern which we share with Mr
Weatherby
is that the reference of paragraph 50 of
council to the inquiries note to
proportionate and focused disclosure is
unclear to us
it appears to be a recipe for potential
arbitrariness in decision making
particularly when you have a very large
team
now we understand Mr Keith's point that
particularly given the scope of the
issues you're dealing with here
adopting his phrase it's neither
necessary nor proportionate for the
inquiry to disclose every document that
it receives
and just to ensure there's no straw men
here we're not proposing that we agree
our primary position in keeping with
with Mr Weatherby is that the test
should be relevance relevance documents
should be disclosed to Corp participants
we accept there needs to be a sift for
relevancy but that's not the test that's
suggested a paragraph 50 of cancel to
the inquiries note
we agree that irrelevant documents or
duplicated documents don't need to be
disclosed but our position is relevancy
should be the watchword that should be
the test
there is of course an alternative
potential compromise which we raised in
our written submissions if you're
against us on a relevancy test
and that is the idea of a schedule of
undisclosed equivalent of a schedule of
unused
now the question put to us this morning
by Mr Keith was to what end it's for the
inquiry to determine whether further
areas are required to be investigated
and he said it was an immense amount of
further work to little end but again we
say give the corps participants some
credit the Corp participants May well
spot in a schedule of undisclosed or a
schedule of unused a key Point unknown
to your inquiry team again we don't say
that to raise any concern about the
diligence or Excellence of your legal
team we say that because the core
participants by virtue of having become
core participants are adding particular
expertise have got a significant
interest or have played a significant
role in the issues they know matters
which simply may be unknown to your team
and we say there is a good end
and again there's of course also a good
end in principle when we go back to the
very first point that I made a little
earlier about transparency and openness
and collaboration
so against that backdrop we do ask that
you consider adopting a more open and
transparent approach to disclosure
ideally the approach proposed by Mr
Weatherby but there is a compromise
alternative which we say is better than
what is proposed at paragraph 50 but
which we have concerns we do need to
have a safety net so that core
participants can review
see if there may have been a matter
overlooked and make submissions to you
and then of course it will be a matter
for you ultimately as to whether or not
that material should be disclosed we
can't make those submissions if these
decisions are made entirely behind
closed doors and we've indicated in our
written submissions that those forms of
schedules have worked well in other
inquiries and large-scale inquests for
example they were used in the
Hillsborough quest to good end
there's a number of small additional
issues I wish to pick up I won't repeat
all the points in our written
submissions and we're grateful for the
indication from you my lady and from Mr
Keith this morning that a number of
matters raised in our written
submissions have now been resolved or
have fallen away we're grateful for that
uh before I move to three short points
we want to address at the end
TUC also wishes to support the
submissions made
in relation to the devolved Nations by
Mr Weatherby King's Council Mr Lavery
King's Council Miss Mitchell King's
Council and Miss Heaven uh this morning
but there's three short matters we want
to highlight now drawing on our written
submissions one is specifically about
module one my lady and two are more
General
ah
I'm just wondering
what I was wondering about the whether I
need to need to break that might be
advisable and then we can look forward
to hearing the remainder of muscatica's
submissions after I'm sorry we've
interacted well I'm very happy to do
that I'm so sorry I didn't know which
but it also saves you having to to rush
through it because we um obviously I'm
meant to be taking a break for the
stenographer transcribers anyway so
um
we haven't really decided how long to
have for braids anybody have any
thoughts as to
I'm happy to come back whenever anybody
wants me to but I want people to have
enough time to
could could my lady in indicate two
o'clock is that just short of an hour
and that's a sort of customary amount of
time isn't it right
um very well so um thank you I'm just
gonna if you then you can um finish your
submissions this afternoon and um also I
think we've got two other
um the tanker and spearing who want to
speak uh and then I'll hear whether Mr
Keith has any submissions by word reply
so thank you very much indeed thank you
and we'll see you this afternoon thank
you two o'clock please
thank you
right next I think we have um the tanker
Ruth hanker
oh so this guy I'm so sorry how could I
do that to you I do apologize thank you
um my lady and if I could start by just
apologizing to the stenographer for
overrunning my time a little early it
does mean this morning I have made
myself deeply unpopular uh by going into
lunchtime over the sound of growling
stomachs which I didn't hear I've quoted
Donald Rumsfeld the U.S Secretary of
Defense a former and for once I was the
Irish person in the room who was not
complaining about pronunciation of my
name so quite a few firsts
um could I just pick up there's two
short supplementary points arising from
the disclosure submissions I made before
I turn to just some final comments on
behalf of the TUC when we refer to the
schedule of undisclosed I'm just asked
to make two short supplementary points
on that the first is of course that all
core participants have signed the
confidentiality undertakings and are
entirely committed to your process and
to the confidentiality of your process
and the second is that the TUC
submission is that this should not be of
us amount of extra work as internally
assist for relevancy will of course have
been undertaken those engaged in
documents review necessarily won't be
operating in a vacuum and will be giving
some form of summary internally to your
team about the decision they've made or
what the document is now we say that not
underestimating the significant and
onerous task being undertaken by Council
to the inquiry and solicitor to the
inquiry we recognize that any additional
task does add to that burden but in our
submission the balance currently as
described in paragraph 50 are
proportionate and focused test applied
by the inquiries legal Team without more
and without oversight is striking the
balance wrongly and this would be an
appropriate alternative
I mentioned just before lunch that we
had three short final matters I'm afraid
given lunch time it's now five but they
are brief so the first is in respect of
module one
and the public hearings we share the
concern raised by Mr Weatherby earlier
about the four-week time estimate you'll
have seen this in our written
submissions of paragraph 34. our view is
that four weeks for this module seems
exceptionally tight particularly given
those six detailed subtopics in the
provisional scope outline so with each
of those topics and with opening and
closing statements you'd be left within
the region of three days per topic and
we think that recognize you don't need
to cover absolutely everything in the
public hearing but that chance we would
say towards the superficial and is too
short
we also bear in mind at the important
nuanced submissions that have been made
before you by a number of core
participants today about the
differential position of the devolved
Nations just by way of example in
respect of Northern Ireland you've had
powerful submissions made today about
the differential position in relation to
Health and Social care The Amalgamated
Health and Social care system the not
being an NHS as such and so on and it's
very difficult to see how on one of
those subtopics where Northern Ireland
is so very different you could possibly
in three days examine that issue so our
submission is that four weeks is
extremely tight and we agree entirely
with the importance of getting on with
it and having this module listed quickly
but our submission is that four weeks is
too short we welcome the indication this
morning that that's under review
we don't press you on any particular
time frame nor could we sensibly
pre-disclosure and in circumstances
where
we've heard additional submissions today
which give us pause for thought
but we suggest that it would be
appropriate to have an early recognition
that whatever the correct length of time
is four weeks is too short and we
suggest it will be much easier to block
time in Diaries and then shorten it than
to try to do the other and to try to
shoehorn in an additional four or eight
or whatever number of weeks it is at a
time when Diaries have become busy so we
suggest that that should be dealt with
quickly and the nettle should be grasped
the second point that we wanted to make
concerns a matter raised by Mr
Birmingham this morning Mr Birmingham
this morning raised a concern for the
adhp about not being able to notify
people about core participant status and
the TUC supports Mr Birmingham
submissions on that important point and
needing to keep Corp participant status
secret for a long period of time save
for those who'd signed the
confidentiality undertaking that's a
practically important point for
representative bodies like the TUC like
the adph which have stakeholders and
members that they need to update so we
Echo and support his submissions
third point is about location of the
hearings we've dealt with that in our
written submissions at paragraph 11 to
14. I won't raise all the points but
just in headline
the Tec welcomes the decision to avoid
the inquiry being exclusively
england-centric given its uk-wide Remus
we note that the intention is for public
hearings in modules 2A 2B and 2C to take
place in Scotland Wales and Northern
Ireland respectively and we welcome that
a commitment
we just at this stage note that it may
be for certain later modules that the
TUC may wish to invite you my lady to
consider sitting outside London for at
least part of public hearings even when
there isn't a specific issue about
devolved governments so by way of
example in an impact module it may be
appropriate to proceed on the basis that
London is not the Assumption and that in
fact an impacts module could sensibly
take place in whole or in part in
another part of the UK and we've raised
a particular concern in our written
submissions about England itself
the TUC May and we put it no higher than
this at this stage but given that the
issue was raised in the outline
submissions and this is your first
hearing we thought it's sensible to put
down a marker TUC May later wish to
request that you consider sitting for at
least part of the public hearings in a
later module in another English City
other than London we can't make the
submission firmly at this stage it will
of course depend when we see the later
modules
and we raise it because there are
certain sectors which were significantly
adversely affected by the pandemic in
which workers faced increased risk of
loss of life and other hardships which
are centered in the north of England
and there are also particular issues
arising which will come to much later in
this inquiry about the failure to
speedily respond to developments in
London which could have saved lives in
northern England in Northern Ireland and
elsewhere in the UK and against that
context in circumstances where you
recognize rightly the symbolic
importance of the UK this being a
uk-wide inquiry and we think it must not
be london-centric the norm should not be
London and we may wish to address you on
that at a later stage
fourth points is about the
identification of future modules
now we're conscious from paragraph 24 of
Mr Keith and Council to the inquiries
note that there will later be some
systems modules and some impact modules
we don't yet know the precise shape and
of course we recognize that even when
you tell us more about the shape it may
necessarily change this is an iterative
process as evidence comes in you may
need to add modules and so on
we do think in contrast to some other
inquiries which have proceeded in a
modular way
where the initial list of modules was
given earlier we think the fact that the
initial list of modules is not published
is likely to cause some problems maybe
just give two examples firstly you may
have core participants or reputative
core participants applying for modules
which are not the most relevant to them
and if they have the full list they may
be able to make a different decision
we're conscious that a number of those
who applied were told well you may want
to waste and apply for a laser module
but if they knew what the later modules
were that were coming they may be less
likely to make an application early
which you think is better placed at a
later stage we're mindful of the fact
you had 130 applications and that of
course adds to the onerous task that
your legal team is undertaking
secondly it would assist with us being
able as core participants to make
focused and targeted scope submissions
by way of one very small example an
indication was given in Mr weatherby's
submissions on behalf of the Brave
families about places of detention it
may well be that you think places of
detention is going to be considered in a
later module module one is not the place
for it at the moment we simply don't
know so it means we're having to make
submissions a little in the dark because
we don't know the later intended shape
and we think it would assist all of us
if we could have the intended shape
public earlier and we hope that would
also take some pressure from your team
so we raised that in a constructive way
we hope the fifth point that we want to
raise and the final one concerns the
issue of balance and we do Echo some
submissions made by Mr Birmingham for
the association of directors of Public
Health this morning on this point we've
dealt with this in writing at paragraphs
15 to 19 of our written submissions and
I take it shortly that you will be aware
that the TUC and the British Medical
Association were originally refused core
participant status in this module and
the original list of 26 core
participants was very heavily weighted
towards officialdon towards government
and public bodies of 26 core
participants originally granted that
status
there were the four bereaved family
groups
it was Imperial College and the others
were all public bodies in some shape or
form that's over 80 percent now we
recognize of course and we do not
question in any way those that have been
granted Corp participants status here
were very grateful for the
reconsideration given to the TUC and
indeed author for the BMA and at this
stage we simply raise a concern that
going forward we're in the foothills of
this inquiry now at the early stages
non-officialdom non-governmental bodies
non-public bodies have a real and
valuable role to play and I hope we as
the TUC can show you that in module one
and going forward and we raise this
simply because we are concerned
that decision making which tends to lean
towards governments will mean
essentially that you have a skewed
process and that's not something which
you want it's not something which we
want and we raise it here against the
backdrop of us having originally been
refused a decision which we're very
grateful to have had overturned and
we're now here we wish to play a
collaborative and constructive role in
the inquiry but we also wish to ensure
that other non-official voices going
forward are given appropriate ways and
are given core participant status where
appropriate and he gets that backdrop we
understood from the initial decision
that it may perhaps have been thought
that the TUC was an impact module type
core participant I hope it's now clear
that we are also a systems module type
core participants and there will be
other non-governmental non-public body
organizations which are valuable
evidence to give you in relation to
systems but who will also be able to
play a valuable role as a core
participant including the right to make
submissions to shape the provisional
scope outline itself having access to
the disclosure being able to test the
evidence of institutional Witnesses and
indeed suggesting lines of inquiry and
against that backdrop my lady there are
submissions thank you very much and
James got it all extremely constructive
and I'm very grateful to you both of you
all written and all submissions and a
number of the issues you rate have
caused me particular concern
um so I can assure you that um I am very
receptive to some of them I don't know
whether I can reflect
um all your submissions and my decisions
but I will consider them very carefully
very great thank you
right having called on the second
prematurely
um
she around
thank you
my lady pronoun Dar Ruth Henke on behalf
of the Welsh government
the Welsh government would like to take
this opportunity to confirm once more
its wholehearted commitment to giving
you and your team the fullest possible
cooperation in investigating its
response to the unprecedented challenges
faced by everyone in Wales every Public
Authority and every business in Wales as
a result of the pandemic
my lady the first Minister on behalf of
the entire Welsh government shares your
commitment to putting the bereaved those
who have suffered hardship and those who
were affected by the decisions of the
government of the UK at the heart of
this inquiry
the Welsh government will make good that
commitment by fully cooperating with
this investigation
are overriding aim is to assist you in
your task of ensuring that those in
particular those who lost their loved
ones have all their questions asked and
received the complete and candid answers
we acknowledge they rightly deserve
the Welsh government is committed to
learning not only the lessons of this
continuing pandemic but also to ensure
that future Welsh governments are in the
best position to respond to Future
public health challenges my lady Diego
Thank you thank you very much indeed
thank you
spearing
foreign
I represent the UK Health Security
Agency firstly there are no written
submissions from Those whom I represent
no discourages intended by that
I certainly only have in fact three
short points and one response to a
submission that my clients would wish to
raise the first is that like many others
who appear before you today at the UK
health and Security Agency are
absolutely committed to assisting you
with this very challenging process
the second is that we will do all we can
in order to facilitate and respond and
we have been thus far working well with
all of those parties who have been
communicating with the agency
the third is in fact important that
we Zoo support the submissions that
Council to the inquiry Mr Keith has
already represented and I don't repeat
those we support and endorse the careful
consideration that he has given in
dialogue with many of the core
participants about the challenges that
this inquiry will present
and finally it's a response to a
submission and that is in relation to
the importance which you've already
raised of of good dialogue of
collaborative and cohesive conversations
in order to be able to respond whether
that be to the rule 9 disclosure
requests to the practicalities of
challenges that this very novel inquiry
will present to many of the participants
the position statements which have been
raised by many my lady we ask that you
bear in mind the challenges that many of
the core participants will have where
multiple individuals may have moved
between agencies
may be working in current organizations
with status who may have been linked at
two core participants where such
boundaries May in fact Hinder
access or perhaps legal advice where
those firm position statements or sought
which then may prevent the expeditious
exploration of facts and information to
be importantly provided to your team so
those are all submissions and everything
they want us to say thank you very much
thank you very much indeed
right Mr Keith do you have any
observations by way of response my lady
thank you there is obviously a great
deal to reflect upon and manage for you
to determine in due course but may I
express my gratitude for
uh they're very helpful
informative submissions which which have
been made
um the manner and the style
in which they have been Advanced and the
matters that they have covered are a
testament to the collaborative approach
um for which I and others have been
advocating
and my lady some of the points simply
can't be responded to today and nor
would you expect them to be not least
because
um some of them are technical some of
them are specific and would require will
require
um considerable thought and reflection
and therefore it's best that I simply
don't Venture into some particular
territories
in relation to panelists
um
my lady in relation to that issue
I would strongly suggest that that is a
a matter for the Prime Minister as the
sponsoring Minister
um it is for her to decide whether to
appoint other panel members to sit with
you
um and therefore although Malone friend
has invited you to contribute to the
decision
to lend support to the appointment of
other panel members but may I invite you
to resist that invitation however
attractively Advanced it is it is simply
not a matter for debate
foreign
outline of scope and the complaint was
reiterated that there had been no
Advance opportunity in advance to the
promulgation of that document
for core participants to to make their
submissions and to make their positions
plain
milady
the outline scope document preceded the
appointment of Court participants and
therefore there was procedurally no
means by which fairly persons who may
have an interest in due course could
have contributed to that process but in
any event
the inquiry had to start somewhere and
fairness and transparency requires a
proper opportunity for comment which of
course has been demonstrated today and
exemplified in the written submissions
and therefore there has been no
unfairness done by virtue of an absence
of an anterior opportunity to comment
in relation to some of the points made
in relation to scope for for module one
a submission was Advanced to the effect
that
the outliner scope document failed to
make sufficiently plain that module one
had covered
all four nations and of course dealt
with and would deal will deal with
reserved and evolved matters
it is that there is only one Express
reference on the face of the outline of
scope document to the United Kingdom
scope of that module and of course to
the need to examine default and Reserve
matters but it is absolutely apparent
from the detail of the rule 9 requests
which have gone out or will go out
to Scotland Wells and Northern Ireland
that the scope of module one indubitably
includes all the errors arising
across the United Kingdom that are
relevant to preparedness and resilience
and and it simply cannot sensibly be
suggested otherwise
module one it was suggested furthermore
but might not be looking at issues of
discrimination and disproportionate
impact
the lady the degree to which government
structures as part of their preparedness
considered
discrimination and the possibility of
disproportionate impact on a variety of
sectors and groups is an evidential
issue which will be considered
what cannot be considered however of
course
it is how in a more granular way
each part of the government preparedness
structure
should
have provided for the needs of each of
those sectors to which it necessarily
had regard so putting it another way
we will and must look at
General Degree of preparedness or lack
thereof and the extent to which the
government did have
the variety of groups and persons and
and people to whom I preferred in mind
but it won't form part of the inquiries
job
try to replicate that process and to try
to draw up detailed plans in place of
what the government did that that is not
the focus of module one
planning
within the social care sector
again scrutiny of how the government
prepared
necessarily includes an examination of
the degree to which they had that sector
and others in mind
and then there are the three procedural
pillars
disclosure of the rule 9 requests
position statements and the disclosure
of
lists of undisclosed documents to call
participants and my lady there is no
legal requirement as I have said
that has in certain instances been a
practice of disclosure of each of those
documents but but there is by no means
an overwhelming case for them or a nor
has an overwhelming case been
established by practice
it will be my lady a MATA in your
absolute discretion to decide what best
promotes fairness and efficiency
in relation to disclosure of
the instructions to experts I've already
said that the inquiry will disclose
those instructions and they will be
disclosed at a sensible stage which
permits the core participants to be able
to comment on the width of the expert
reports framed by those instructions
at a time which allows enough
opportunity thereafter for the reports
to be varied before they reach their
final emanation that that is good
sensible practice I would suggest
disclosure
there has been some comment made in
relation to the approach adopted by
council's inquiry in paragraph 49 of the
written submissions to disclosure my
lady may I see streets away the
paragraph 49 expresses itself as a name
it is not the standard it may be thought
that it is dancing on the head of a pen
to try and distinguish between what is
proportionate and focused and relevant
but I have said this morning and I
repeat of course the court participants
will receive material that is relevant
and in our inquiry and the throwing out
of a net wide enough
to receive relevant material we will
look for material that is potentially
relevant
I don't propose to say anything about
the listening exercise
um but turning finally to the question
of the retention of documents
um the point was made forcibly on behalf
of adph that
the retention of documents warning that
Mr Connor sent out in January but may
not have been wide enough to go beyond
the demands that it placed upon central
government can I say that that the
letter invited and made perfectly plain
to central government that the warning
was to be promulgated to all bodies
exercising public functions and
therefore the necessarily includes local
government
um finally my lady
that there was um there were
oh well I should say in in the context
of the issue of the overwhelming and
um plain obligation to retain documents
that I believe that Mr Smith will be
when preparing the redaction protocol
for the benefits of document providers
that he will emphasize re-emphasize of
course the message on the overarching
obligation to retain and preserve
material
there was a final submission in relation
to the need for remote location made by
Leading cancer on behalf of Scottish
covid-19 brewed families for justice and
we will give urgent consideration to
setting up the inquiry by way of remote
location to allow persons to view and
follow these proceedings online
that is all that I propose to say in
relation to the submissions which have
been Advanced on behalf of the core
participants unless there's anything
else that you would wish me to address
thank you very much Mr Keith
um and I thank all the core participants
those who've made all submissions and
those who've made both oral and written
submissions they've all been extremely
constructive and helpful and I repeat I
am very grateful to them and for the
office of support because to be frank
we're going to need it we have a huge
task ahead and we will need the support
of everybody particularly the core
participants and
um with that support I hope we can
achieve the aims that I set out earlier
so thank you all very much indeed and
thank you to those who've come who
didn't have a speaking role we do
appreciate your interest in everything
that's going on so thank you all
all right
foreign